EVERYONE. GOOD MORNING WELCOME
TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE THIS IS COMMITTEES AT
THIRTY HEARING THIS SESSION OF
WHICH WE WILL HEAR NEW AUDIT
REQUEST WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES IN OTHER COMMITTEES
AS WELL LOOK FORWARD TO A
PRODUCTIVE HEARING TODAY I WILL
ANNOUNCE TODAY THAT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TYLER DEEP WILL BE
REPLACED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT CHAD MAYES.
AND I WILL ALSO ANNOUNCE THAT
TODAY WE HAVE AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER FOUR TWENTY NINETEEN
DASH ONE TWO SIX TRI CITY
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIRD A ****
BATH. HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA. DO WE HAVE ONE.
OKAY WE'RE MISSING ONE MORE
MEMBER FOR A QUORUM WE WILL
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
OPERATE IS SUBCOMMITTEE INTEL
FORM IS ESTABLISHED WITH THAT I
BELIEVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
WAS SIGNED IN FIRST. ACTUALLY
GIVE ME ONE MOMENT. I THINK WE
HAVE A QUORUM NOW. PHONE TWO
REQUIREMENTS RIGHT WAS SECTOR
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. SOME
REMEMBER SALAS PRESIDENT.
BOERNER HORVATH. MAYES
PATTERSON. RUBIO VOEPEL. WHAT
SENATOR ROCK BARGES. YEAH
GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG MORNING.
MOORLACH WIENER. OKAY A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
THAT BEGIN ON TODAY'S AGENDA
ITEM WILL START WITH THE CHEN
ITEM NUMBER ONE A PRESENTATION
BY THE STATE AUDITOR ON THE
STATUS REPORT AND WORK IN
PROGRESS BETTER MONITOR WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURST FOR THE RECORD
MY NAME'S ELAINE HOW CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR I'LL MAKE MY
STATUS REPORT QUICK I KNOW IT'S
A BUSY TIME OF YEAR WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SIXTEEN AUDITS
IN PROGRESS WE HAVE STARTED ALL
BUT ONE AUDITS THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS APPROVED THIS
YEAR THE ONE AUDIT THAT'S
WAITING STAFF AND WE HAVEN'T
STARTED YET AS YOU'LL RECALL IS
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. A
REQUEST BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURNER **** BATH THAT REQUEST
TO MAKE COMMITTEE VOTED TO HAVE
US WAIT UNTIL YOU EITHER SIX
MONTHS TAKES PLACE OR
TRANSPIRES OR YOU SEE FINISHES
THEIR SECOND AUDIT THAT THERE
THE SCOPE OF THAT AUDIT IS
RELATED TO THE ADMISSIONS A
SITUATION THAT TRANSPIRED
EARLIER THIS YEAR SO THAT AUDIT
WE HAVE. IT AS THE COMMITTEE
DIRECTED US TO DO WE'VE WAITED
TO STAFF THAT WE WILL. I INTEND
TO COMMENCE THAT IN JANUARY
THAT WOULD BE THE SIX MONTH
WINDOW. I'M NOT SURE WHEN UC'S
GOING TO COMPLETE THEIR WORK
BUT BASED ON WHAT THIS
COMMITTEE DIRECTED US TO DO
INTEND TO START THAT AUDIT IN
JANUARY. EVERYTHING ELSE WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO START
COMMENCE ALSO AT THE LAST
HEARING MEMBERS I MENTIONED WE
HAD THREE STATUTORY AUDITS THAT
WE WERE REQUIRED TO START THIS
YEAR. ON NATIVE AMERICAN GRAVES
PROTECTION AND REPATRIATION ACT
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PROCUREMENT
WHICH WE DO. EVERY YEAR. AND
THEN TOBACCO TAXES. I BELIEVE
IT WAS PROP FIFTY SIX IT
REQUIRES US TO LOOK AT
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS RELATED TO
COLLECTION OF TOBACCO TAX ALL
OF THE STATUTORY AUDITS HAVE
BEEN STAFFED WITH COMMENCED
THOSE PROJECTS. ARE SO WE HAVE.
EVERYTHING IN PROGRESS THE
OTHER WORK IN PROGRESS IS SOME
STATUTORY WORK REQUIRED BY ANY
LEAD TO PUT TOGETHER A HIGH
RISK LIST. OF FOR THE STATE
CALIFORNIA THERE STATE AGENCIES
OR STATE ISSUE AREAS WE ARE
WORK WE HAVE TEAM WORKING ON
THAT THAT'LL BE PUBLISHED IN
JANUARY. AS REQUIRED BY STATE
LAW. ON THE NUMBER OF OUR
REQUESTS AS YOU MENTIONED
MISTER CHAIRMAN NOW TO BE
CONSIDERED TODAY AT FOUR
REQUEST. OUR ESTIMATE OF
STAFFING BETWEEN NOW AND THE
END OF THE CALENDAR YEAR WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO START SEVEN ON
IT SO WE HAVE PLENTY OF STAFF.
A TO START PROJECTS WE BE ABLE
TO COMMENCE ANYTHING THAT'S
APPROVED TODAY. RELATIVELY SOON
I THINK WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF MONTHS. ALSO IT IN THE EVENT.
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT GONNA GET
SEVEN APPROVED TODAY WE DO HAVE
ONE REQUEST MISTER CHAIR YOUR
REQUEST AND OTHER MEMBERS ON
YOUTH SUICIDE THAT ONE IS
REQUIRING US TO GO TO FIVE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS WE'RE
LOOKING AT GOING TO THREE ELLIE
AIZEN PERHAPS TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND WE'LL FIGURE OUT
THE MIX WHAT WE CAN DO WITH
THAT IS PUT ESSENTIALLY TWO
TEAMS ON IT WORKING
CONCURRENTLY SO THAT WE REDUCE
THE CALENDAR TIME FOR
COMPLETING THAT AUDIT WE
CERTAINLY HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
DO THAT. THE ONLY OTHER THING
I'D LIKE TO MENTION MEMBERS AS
WE ARE AS YOU KNOW RESPONSIBLE
FOR CREATING THE NEXT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION FOR
TWENTY TWENTY THE INITIAL
APPLICATION PROCESS COMPLETED.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO OUR PLEASE
AND REALLY PROUD TO ANNOUNCE WE
RECEIVED ALMOST TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS FROM
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SERVE ON THE
COMMISSION THIS SUPPLEMENTAL
APPLICATION PHASE HAS STARTED
THAT'S A THIRTY DAY WINDOW NOW
THAT'S A LITTLE MORE INTENSIVE
APPLICATIONS SO LAST TIME WE
SAW BOB PERHAPS WE'LL SEE IT
BOB THIS TIME BUT WHAT WE
INTEND TO DO ON TO THE EXTENT
WE NEED TO IS IF I NEED TO PULL
AUDIT STAFF TO ASSIST. IN DOING
THAT THE REVIEWS OF THOSE
SUPPLEMENTAL APPLICATIONS
BEFORE WE POST EVERYTHING
ONLINE WE WANT TO REVIEW THINGS
FOR EMBARRASSMENT CHECK WE WANT
TO PUT ANYTHING ON THE WEBSITE
THAT'S OFFENSIVE SO IF I NEED
TO ALL POLL STEPPED OFF BUT WE
CERTAINLY WILL HAVE PLENTY
RESOURCES TO REALLY GET THE
AUDITS DONE AT THAT ON THIS
COMMITTEE APPROVES TODAY. WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIR. I'LL TURN
THE QUESTION. THANK YOU IN
ORDER LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS ON STATUS REPORT.
SAYING NONE AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MEMBERS OF THE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN BOTH HOUSES
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A PROPOSED
CONSENT TO CALENDAR THAT'S
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER ONE CAN HAVE
A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WILL I'M SORRY WE
MUST FIRST BEFORE WE VOTE ON
THESE ITEMS WE MUST SUSPEND J.
LIKE RULED OVER THIRTEEN IN
NUMBER FIFTEEN. AND WITH THAT
I'LL TAKE A MOTION TO WAIVE
THOSE RULES AND PASS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WITH BY
MISTE ROTH SECOND IN BY.
MISTER WOOD. BATTLE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS HI SALAS I
BOERNER HORVATH. MAYES
PATTERSON PATTERSON I RUBIO
RUBIO HIGH VOEPEL. VOEPEL I
WOULD. WHAT I CENTER ROTH ROTH
AYE FORGES OR JUST I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG. MORNING
MORE LIKE. MOORLACH HI WIENER.
OKAY WILL HOLD THAT ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS WITH
THAT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO MISTER
GLORIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
THIS IS AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE I'M SORRY. OKAY SO THE- WE
WILL NEED TO VOTE AGAIN
APPARENTLY THAT WAS THE VOTE
FOR THE SUSPENSION OF THE RULES
AND NOW WE WILL THE- NOW WE
WILL VOTE ON A. THANK CALENDAR.
SO MOVED BY MISTER WOOD SECOND
BY MISTER OSCAR. THANK YOU SIR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THIS MOTION IS
TO APPROVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN DASH
ONE TWENTY FIVE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES SUICIDE
PREVENTION EFFORTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS BY SOUTH HI
BOERNER HORVATH. MAYES.
PATTERSON PATTERSON I RUBIO
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL VOEPEL I WOULD.
WHAT I CENTER ROTH. ROTH HI OR
JUST OR JUST I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. MORNING
MOORLACH. MOORLACH AYE WIENER
WE ARE I. CALENDARS APPROVAL
HOLD THE ROLL UP IN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OKAY NOW WILL
MOVE TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FIVE
TWENTY NINETEEN DASH ONE TWO
SEVEN SAN DIEGO AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA SUMMER LAURIE
WHEN YOU'RE READY MAKES THIS
CHAIRMAN GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
WANT TO SEND YOU AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT ARTS AND YOU
EIGHTY C. D. REPRESENTS OVER
THREE MILLION PEOPLE ACROSS
EIGHTEEN. CITIES IT'S THE ONLY
GOVERNING BOARD OF A LARGE
METROPOLITAN AREA CALIFORNIA
THAT IS GOVERNED SOLELY BY THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
EXCLUDING LOCAL CITIES FROM
HAVING A SEAT ON THE BOARD. THE
ONLY OTHER COUNTY AIR DISTRICTS
ARE GOVERNOR SIMILE ARE SMALLER
PRIMARILY RULE COUNTIES WITH
FAR FEWER AIR POLLUTION SOURCES
I SUCH THAT FINANCES OFFICIAL
ACTIONS ACTIVITIES OF THE SAN
DIEGO AT CD ARE FULLY EMBEDDED
WITHIN THE OPERATIONS OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO AND
THEREFORE DIFFICULT TO EXTRACT
AND EXAMINE. THE CITY TO A PC
IS CURRENTLY THE CURRENT
STUCTURE IN MY JUDGMENT DOES
NOT REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF
OUR SECURITIES RESIDENTS IS
ANTIQUATED IT LEAVES OUT
VALUABLE PERSPECTIVE AND
INSIGHT TO LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
SOURCES THAT CITIES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS MAY BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. IT EVER IN AN EFFORT
TO ADDRESS THIS AS WELL AS THE
NEED FOR CITY WAS QUITE IMPROVE
THE NEED TO IMPROVE AIR QUALITY
INCREASE DIVERSITY ON THE BOARD
OF AUTHORED ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
TWENTY THREE WHICH SEEKS TO
RESTRUCTURE THE SAN DIEGO AT
CITY BORDER MANNER THEY WERE
CLOSELY MATCHES OF OUR BY OUR
ARE SIMILARLY SIZED CITY
CALIFORNIA AREAS. THIS NEW
BOARD SHOULD HAVE COMPLETE
INFORMATION REGARDING SEND YOU
A PCD TO CONSIDER WELL AS THEY
ASSUME THESE RESPONSIBILITIES
SHOULD THE BILL BE SIGNED INTO
LAW THIS AUDIT WILL HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS ON THE BOARDS
FINANCIAL INFORMATION PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES AS IT RELATES TO ITS
FINANCES. AND ON ITS DECISION
MAKING PROCESS SEES. IF A P. C.
F. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR TWENTY
THREE DOES NOT PASS IT IS STILL
IMPORTANT. FOUR EIGHT THAT CITY
WAS A PC'S INFORMATION BE
SEPARATE FROM THE COUNTY THIS
BUDGET IN ORDER TO BETTER AND
THAT WHILE THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND THE FINANCIAL AND
PROGRAMMATIC FUNCTION. OF THIS
KEY PUBLIC AGENCY. INCREASING
IN A MAINTAINING TRANSPARENCY
IN THIS REGARD AS CRUCIAL TO UP
HOLDING A PUBLIC A PALO
ACCOUNTABILITY. AS WE CONTINUE
TO ADDRESS THE SERIOUS AIR
POLLUTION ISSUES IN THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AREA WITH ME THIS
MORNING TO TESTIFIED SUPPORTERS
DâN TALK FOR IN. WITHIN BY THE
HEALTH COALITION. GOOD MORNING.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM DIANNE TECH FOR IN
AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH COALITION.
I ALSO SERVE ON THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AS THE
FIRST ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE BOARD. WE
ARE IN NEARLY FORTY YEAR OLD
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION WE WORK IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND OUR COMMUNITY SUFFER FROM
SOME OF THE WORST AIR POLLUTION
IN. THAT COUNTY AND WE HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF WORKING TO
REDUCE AIR POLLUTION AND
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH. BEFORE
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WHICH ALSO SERVES AS THE
COUNTY'S AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT. WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE
A COSPONSOR A BEFORE TWO THREE
BY MR GLORIA WHICH WILL REFORM
THE SAN DIEGO AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT TO UPDATE IT
TO BE GOVERNED. BY AS LARGE
DISTRICTS ARE IN THE STATE BY A
DIVERSE AND REPRESENTATIVE
BOARD. BUT ON THIS PATH TOWARDS
MODERNIZATION THAT A. B. FOR
TWENTY THREE HAS CREATED.
THERE'S A CRITICAL NEED FOR AN
AUDIT OF THE CURRENT OPERATIONS
OF THE SAN DIEGO AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT THIS IS BECOME
VERY CLEAR. SPECIFICALLY WE ARE
REQUESTING THAT THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
CONDUCT AN AUDIT OF THE A PC
DE. AN EFFORT TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ENSURE THAT
SAN DIEGO CAN HAVE THE CLEANEST
ARE POSSIBLE. LOOKING UP AT A
FEW EXAMPLES FIRST AT THE A. B.
C. D. BUDGET THE SEVENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET IS
INCLUDED IN THE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PAGE COUNTY BUDGET. AS
ONLY ONE PAGE WITH SIX
EXPENDITURE LINE ITEMS. AS AN
EXAMPLE ONE LINE ITEM OTHER
CHARTERS WAS BUDGETED FOR
TWENTY NINE MILLION IN THIS
FISCAL. GIVEN THAT IS NEARLY
HALF OF THE A. B. C. DEEP
BUDGET MORE DETAIL IS CLEARLY
REQUIRED. TO ENABLE THE PUBLIC
TO BE FULLY INFORMED AND TO
UNDERSTAND THE FUNCTIONING OF
THIS AGENCY. ACTUALLY SINCE
THIS AUDIT REQUEST WAS MADE
THERE HAS BEEN MORE DETAIL
THAT'S BEEN ADDED TO THE COUNTY
NARRATIVE AND SO WE THINK THAT
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN. MOVING
TOWARD FURTHER TRANSPARENCY
THAT THIS AUDIT WILL BUY.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE REAL TO A
PLEASE PLEASE CALL ME. AND
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS. LASTLY I'D
SAY THAT ABCD IS
ORGANIZATIONALLY PART OF THE
COUNTY'S LAND USE AND
ENVIRONMENT GROUP. IT APPEARS
THAT A P. C. D. STAFF PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR ACTIVITIES WITHIN
THIS UNIT THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE RELATED TO A P. C. D. STATED
MISSION IN AND FULFILLMENT OF
THEIR REGULATORY AND STATUTORY.
RESPONSIBILITIES LEGITIMATE
PUBLIC QUESTIONS RELATED TO
THESE ACTIVITIES THAT I THINK
COULD BE ANSWERED BY THE AUDIT.
OUR OUR THESE SERVICES PAID FOR
THAT BY THE COUNTY OR BY
ANOTHER FUNDING SOURCE DO THESE
SERVICES DETRACT FROM
FULFILLMENT OF EIGHT CITIES
MISSION. I HAVE NO DOUBT. AT
THE CAPABLE AND COMMITTED STAFF
OF A. B. C. D. ARE COMMITTED TO
TAKING BOLD AND EFFECTIVE
ACTION TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE ENVIRONMENT AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND SINCE THE
INTRODUCTION OF A BEFORE TWO
THREE THERE'S BEEN A RIP ROBUST
AND COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSION AT
THAT HAS EMERGED WITH CLEAR
IMPROVEMENTS AND I BELIEVE THAT
THIS AUDIT WILL FURTHER THAT
THAT EFFORT SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AT THIS TIME WILL
MOVE TO THE STATE AFTER PLEASE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA'S ASKED
US OBVIOUSLY TO LOOK AT THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT IN
SAN DIEGO FIRST OBJECTIVE IS
REALLY LOOKING AT THEIR
PROCEDURES THEIR PROCESSES FOR
DECISION MAKING WITH RESPECT TO
ENVIRONMENTAL DECISIONS PUBLIC
HEALTH DECISIONS. HE'S ASKING
US TO LOOK AT A FOUR YEAR
WINDOW NOT ONLY FOR THAT BUT
FOR OTHER. OBJECTIVES IN THE IN
THE AUDIT REQUEST SPECIFICALLY
ASKING US TO LOOK AT THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BUDGET. AND REALLY
TRYING TO DRILL DOWN AND LOOK
AT REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES
RELATED TO AIR POLLUTION
CONTRO DISTRICT FUNCTIONS
INSPECTIONS ENFORCEMENT.
AMOUNTS PAID FOR EQUIPMENT
ETCETERA PERMIT FEE REVENUE SO
REALLY TRYING TO DRILL DOWN
INTO INTO THAT INFORMATION
GETTING A HANDLE ON IT OVER A
FOUR YEAR WINDOW FOR FISCAL
YEARS. IN ADDITION TO THAT
LOOKING AT STAFFING LOOKING AT
WORK. ON THE TIME THAT STAFF
ARE SPENDING EITHER ON AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
FUNCTIONS OR ARE SOME OF THOSE
STAFF PERFORMING. A WRIST
PERFORMING DUTIES OUTSIDE THE
SCOPE OF WHAT THE DISTRICT A
STAFFER SUPPOSED TO BE DOING SO
MAKING SURE THAT STAFF ARE. ARE
INVESTING THEIR TIME IN EFFORTS
RELATED TO AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT FUNCTIONS. IN
ADDITION HE HAS ASKED US TO
LOOK AT THE BUDGETING PROCESS
SO HOW DOES THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT PUT TOGETHER
THEIR PIECE OF. THE COUNTY'S
BUDGET TO BE ROLLED UP INTO THE
INTO THE BIGGER BUDGET AND
AGAIN LOOKING AT A FOUR YEAR
WINDOW. THE LAST TWO OBJECTIVES
REALLY FOCUS ON GRANTS HAVE
THERE BEEN ANY GRANTS AWARDED
TO THE DISTRICT. HOW HOW MUCH
ARE THOSE GRANTS FOR. AND HAS
THE DISTRICT COMPLIED WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THOSE GRANT
GRANT. DOCUMENTS AND THEN THE
LAST BIG ISSUE IS LOOKING AT
OUT REACH HOW HAS THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
REACHED OUT TO THE COMMUNITY
SOLICITED INPUT FROM THE
COMMUNITY HE WANTS US TO
COMPARE THAT TO IS COMPARABLE
DISTRICTS WILL LOOK TO SEE
DISTRICTS OF SIMILAR SIZE.
PERHAPS SIMILAR CONSTRUCTION
I'M NOT SURE IT SEEMS LIKE
THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
BUT WHAT WILL UP FIGURE THAT
OUT AS WE GO BUT HOW THE
INFORMANT COMMUNITIES ASKING US
ARE THEY ARE COMMUNICATING
INFORMATION IN VARIOUS
LANGUAGES SO THAT PEOPLE CAN BE
ENGAGED IN THE VARIOUS
PROCESSES. IF THERE ARE
INCREASE FROM THE PUBLIC HOW
ARE THEY RESPONDING TO THOSE IN
CORY'S ARE THOSE RESPONSES
TIMELY ARE THEY COMPLETE
ETCETERA. AND THEN THE FINAL
PIECE OF OUT REACH IS REALLY
THEIR PUBLIC MEETINGS ARE THEY
COMPLYING WITH OPEN MEETINGS
LAWS SO A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
THINGS WITH RESPECT TO OUR
REGION ENGAGING WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND SAN DIEGO. ON THE
BUDGET FOR THIS AUDIT ABOUT
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED HOURS THAT
WOULD TAKE ONE TEAM WE THINK
ONE TEAM MAKES SENSE ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT ABOUT SIX
MONTHS WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR
I'LL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AT THIS TIME WE
TURN IT BACK OVER TO THE DYESS
ME ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS ON THE
DíAS. MR WARLOCK. PLEASE MAKE
MIXTURE I'M- JUST CURIOUS. WE
JUST HAD A- HEARING ON THE-
GAMBLING COMMISSION AND THEY
DIDN'T HAVE VERY GOOD. BUDGET
DETAILS ON THEIR WEBSITE EITHER
SO I'M- JUST SORT OF CURIOUS.
THE CINNAMON. GLORIA DID YOU
WORK WITH THE AUDITOR
CONTROLLER FOR THE- COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO TO GET SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION. WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE COUNTY THAT THE THAT
REPRESENTED IN THE AUDIENCE BUT
AND THEY'VE BEEN GENERALLY OF
GREAT TO WORK WITH AS
DESTRUCTOID MENTION WHO ALREADY
GETTING SOME ADDITIONAL DETAILS
ON AS A RESULT OF OUR
QUESTIONS. BUT THIS IS SIR TO
PORTANTINO'S RELATES THAT
LEGISLATION INTRODUCED AB FOR
TWENTY THREE IF IT'S RATIFIED
SIGNED INTO LAW THE NEW BOARD
IT WOULD ASSUME THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES I THINK WE OWE
IT TO THEM TO GIVE THEM A FULL
UNDERSTANDING AN ACCOUNTING OF
HOW THE CITY TO A P. C. BOARD
HAD. IT WORKS WHAT'S THE
STATE'S FINANCES HOW IS THE
OPERATION WORKING AS THEY SOON
THEIR NEW DUTIES AGAIN IF THE
BILL IS PASSED AND IF NOT I
THINK TO YOUR QUESTION YOU'RE
THE KIND OF TRANSPARENCY I
THINK IT IS THAT IS A- INCOME
UPON PUBLIC AGENCIES. THIS
AUDIT WOULD HELP FOR THAT AND
PERHAPS ALLOWED TO COUNTY TO BE
MORE ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PUBLIC
IS BEING THERE THAT THEY'RE
REGULATING. BUT YOU HAVEN'T.
PURSUED A PUBLIC RECORDS
REQUEST OR YOU HAVEN'T. WITH
THE AUDITOR CONTROLLER JUST
INDEPENDENT WE TRY TO GET SOME
OF THIS INFORMATION IS THAT
CORRECT I MYSELF HAVE NOT I
KNOW OTHERS. I'M JUST. THE
REASON I ASK IS WE PAY PRETTY
AYE BILLING RATE. TO OUR
AUDITORS AND SOME OF THAT STUFF
MAYBE WE COULD SAVE SOME MONEY
ON SITES. LET'S REASON FOR MY
QUESTION THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF JUST SETTING THE STATE
AUDITOR'S WORTH EVERY PENNY.
WILL MOVE TO SENATOR BORDERS
AND TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN YEAH I'M
KIND OF FOLLOW ALONG THE SAME
LINES THIS IS DESIGNED TO BEING.
COMPLIMENTARY TO AB FOUR TWO
THREE WHICH IS IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS RIGHT NOW. HAD
YOU CONSIDERED MAYBE MAKING
THIS AUDIT CONTINGENT UPON
PASSAGE OF FOUR TO THREE I KNOW
YOU PROVIDED RATIONALE FOR IN
THE EVENT THAT FOR TWO THREE
DOESN'T PASS. THE SENATE AND
GET SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR. TO
RESTRUCTURE THE LOCAL AIRBOARD.
I GUESS I'M SHOULD TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE IS THE
COMPELLING NEED. BECAUSE
TRANSPARENCY DOES IT NORMALLY
TRIGGER AT LEAST IN MY OPINION
COMPELLING NEED TO USE THE
RESOURCES OF THE AUTHOR
NORMALLY THERE'S A CONTROVERSY.
AND QUESTIONS ABOUT PERFORMANCE
AND HOW IN ENTITIES RELATES
SELF WITH GOOD PRACTICE AND I
JUST I JUST DON'T SEE. WHERE IS
THE CONTROVERSY HERE. WELL THE
LIMITED MANDATE LET ME HAVE A
GO AT IT SO I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS VERY MUCH
OF SAN DIEGO ISSUE SIDE RESPECT
AND UNDERSTAND IF THIS IS NOT A
PART OF YOUR DAILY NEWS HABIT
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT IT WHETHER
IT IS A MANUFACTURER THAT'S
PAYING A FEE FOR INTERFACE WITH
A PCD BUT WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT
FEE IS INCLUSIVE OF THINGS
OUTSIDE OF THE OPERATIONS AS
WAS MENTIONED I MISS TACK FOUR
IN THE SUPPORTED ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS THAT ARE HARD TO SEE YOU
KNOW THAT AND THAT WOULD. BE
VERY COULD BE IN VIOLATION OF
STATE LAW BUT THAT'S NOT YOUR
JURISDICTION THAT WOULD BE THE
PRIMACY OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THAT COMPRISES THE
AIRBOARD WELL SENATOR YOU'RE
ASKING FOR WHAT'S THE WHAT'S
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL WHAT I
PROMISE AT EIGHTEEN POINT A
LACK OF BUT WELL STATE LAW THAT
I'M REFERRING TO WEBSITE IF
THERE'S A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
IN THE FEES AND IF WE KEEP IT
WITH IF MISS HOUSE ARE ALLOWED
TO DO HER WORK I THINK WE'LL BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER NOT
THOSE FEES ARE PROPERLY PRICED.
AND IF A MALE TO BE LOWER OR
HIGHER BASED UPON THAT THIS IS
A PART OF YOUR BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO I THINK THAT
THAT'S WORTHWHILE BUT PROBABLY
THE MAUVE ARCHING ISSUE IS THAT
SAN DIEGO HAS THE SIX FORCED
AIR QUALITY IN THE UNITED
STATES AND THAT'S A MAJOR
CONCERN THAT IS A SCANDAL WORTH
LOOKING AT AND THIS IS THE
AGENCY THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE REGULATION OF THAT AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT IT IS DIFFERENT
THAN ITS COMPETITOR UP AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS THE NEED FOR
THE BILL BUT THE CHANCE PARENTS
WERE TALKING ABOUT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT. LASTLY SIR THIS IS
PUBLIC MONEY IN SO I WOULD
CHALLENGE ANY MEMBER OF THIS
BOARD WHETHER NOT YOU WANT TO
SIGN UP FOR MAKING IT HARDER TO
ASCERTAIN WHERE THIS MONEY IS
GOING WHAT'S COMING FROM AND
WHERE IT'S GOING ON THIS AUDIT
WOULD WOULD CORRECT THAT AND
THAT WOULD BE VALUABLE WHETHER
OR NOT THERE'S INDEPENDENT A
PCD WITH A CONTINUES TO BE
HOUSED WITHIN THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO. WELL I BEING FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH HAS THE
WORST AIR IN CALIFORNIA I HAVE.
A SOFT SPOT FOR THIS TYPE OF
ISSUE. I HAVEN'T SEEN FOR TWO
THREE YET. I THINK IN THEORY
THOUGH. I LIKE THE IDEA. OF
INCLUDING. OTHER MUNICIPALITIES
IN IMPACTED REGIONS. I THINK
THAT IS A HEALTHY THING. I
THINK IT. WAS A BUT I GUESS YOU
KNOW ALL ALL IN MY COMMENTS
HERE THAT. IF WE WERE LOOKING
AT TRANSPARENCY AS BEST POLICY
AND PRACTICE WROTE CALIFORNIA.
WE WOULD OVERWHELM THE LIMITED
RESOURCES THAT YOUR OFFICE HAS.
AND SO WE HAVE TO BE CHOOSY AND
DISCREET AND SELECTIVE. ABOUT
WHERE WE MAKE THAT INVESTMENT
AND WITHOUT CONTROVERSY IN MY
OPINION. I JUST DON'T SEE THE
COMPELLING NEED. THAT'S JUST MY
PERSONAL HAS MEDITATE ENGINEER
BY SENATOR. THAT THANK CENTER
BORDERS AND YEAH AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY WE ACTUALLY DO
INCLUDE ARE SMALL CITIES ON THE
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD AS WELL AND SO I
SEE THAT YOUR REQUEST KIND OF
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THAT. BRING
THAT TRANSPARENCY AS WELL WITH
THAT LET'S GO TO MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL. I HAVE
A COMMENTS AND SOME QUESTIONS
MY VERY GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN
DIEGO. GOOD FOR FROM CITY. AND
SPEAKING OF SANTEE IT'S A SMALL
MEDIUM SIZED CITY ALONG WITH EL
CAJON OF MY DISTRICT NOW ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS I HAVE WITH THIS
AND- FOR TWENTY THREE. IS FOR
MANY YEARS THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I BELIEVE IN MY
OPINION HAS DONE A VERY GOOD
JOB. CONTROLLING AIR POLLUTION
AND MONETARY. ONE OF THE WILD
CARDS THAT. MAY NOT BE KNOWN TO
THIS COMMITTEE IS TO A ONE OF
MEXICO. WE GET A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF POLLUTION UNDER
CONTROL ABSOLUTELY. SPEWING OUT
OF THAT AREA DEPENDING UPON THE
TIME OF YEAR AND JET STREAM
EXCEPT FOR. SO. ONE THING NICE
ABOUT THE CURRENT SET UP IS THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAVE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
TIJUANA TRYING TO DO WHATEVER
THEY CAN DO TO HELP OUT THERE.
SO. ANOTHER ISSUE WITH FOR
TWENTY THREE AND HOW IT
DOVETAILS INTO THIS REQUEST IS
IF. THEY GO TO A DIFFERENT
STRUCTURE. I'M ASSUMING WITH
ALMOST 95% ASSUMPTION THAT IT
WILL BENEFIT LARGE CITIES OVER
THE SMALL CITIES UNDER THE
CURRENT SANDBAGS SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF. GOVERNMENTS
IT'S A WAITED VOTE WHICH MEANS
SAN DIEGO BASICALLY ALONG WITH
THE COUNTY DOMINATES. I BELIEVE
THIS WOULD BE A WAITED VOTE.
ELIMINATING THE COUNTY TO SOME
EXTENT SO WE GO FROM FAIR
REPRESENTATION WITH FIVE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS THAT ARE ELECTED
FROM THEIR DISTRICTS SO YOU
HAVE DIVERSITY THERE. AND SAN
DIEGO POLITICALLY IS TURNING
BLUE. A BLUE SO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN FUTURE ELECTIONS
ARE GOING TO BE TURNED OVER
ANYWAY. SO TO ME THIS HOLD. AB
FOR TWENTY THREE STRUCTURE. IS
NOT NEEDED. ALSO. THE AUDIENCE
IS REDUNDANT EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
THREE INCLUDES A REQUIREMENT
FOR THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO
COMPLETE A PROGRAM AUDIT. BY
JUNE FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF
THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL BOARD.
THIS AUDIT WOULD BE DUPLICATIVE
OF THOSE EFFORTS ALSO I BELIEVE
THAT IF A SIMPLE REQUEST IS
MADE THEY WOULD BE MORE THAN
GLAD TO COMPLY. VOLUNTARILY
OPENER BOOKS OPEN EVERYTHING SO.
TO ME THIS IS OVERKILL WE'RE
WE'RE GOING TO BE HIT THEM WHAT
TO ORDER IT'S ESSENTIALLY. IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME THERE.
IN THIS REQUEST IS PREMATURE.
WE'RE GONNA SPEND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ON AN
AUDIT. THAT WILL BE DONE
BEFORE. AN AUDIT BY FOUR TWENTY
THREE. IT'S ABSOLUTE OVER KILL.
AND THAT'S BASICALLY MY
COMMENTS I HAD A QUESTION BUT
I'VE ANSWERED MY OWN MIND
ALRIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR STATEMENT
WITH THAT LET ME ASK IF THERE'S
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FOR
MEMBERS ON THE DíAS. HEARING
AND SEEING NINE MISSED WORRY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SURE
LET ME JUST TACKLE ONE QUESTION
THAT. MY COLLEAGUE FOR SANTEE
MENTION THERE IS A REQUEST OF
FOR CARB TO PERFORM AN AUDIT OF
ITS OWN THAT'S A PERFORMANCE
AUDIT IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT WE'RE ASKING. IS HOW TO DO
AND MISS TACKLING'S HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
IF YOU LIKE BUT I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERATION I NOTE THAT WE DO
HAVE THE COUNTY IN THE AUDIENCE
HERE TODAY AND I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY PUBLICLY
APPRECIATION. FOR THEIR
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT IN WORKING
ON THIS BILL YOU SEE THAT
THEY'RE NOT OPPOSED TO THIS
LEGISLATION I THINK THEY SEE IT
AS A POSITIVE STEP FORWARD FOR
US THE QUALITY OF LIFE IN SAN
DIEGO A REGION. HOWEVER IT'S
STILL A POINT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE DO NOT YET KNOW THE COMPLETE
SCOPE OF THE SITUATION AND THAT
IS WHY THIS AUDIT IS SO VERY
NECESSARY A TO INCREASE
TRANSPORT TRANSPARENCY AND TO
PROVIDE THE NEW BOARD. WITH ALL
THE RELEVANT INFORMATION THAT
IT MUST HAVE AS IT TAKES OF THE
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
BRING A PUBLIC AGENCY IN THE
COUNTY OF SAN. DIEGO IS FOR
THAT REASON I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EITHER. OKAY THANK RESTORE
AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO AFFECTED AGENCIES IF WE HAVE
ANY AFFECTED AGENCIES OF LIKE
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY. PLEASE
THERE IS. THE MORNING SURE
SOUNDS VICE CHAIR ROTH JONATHAN
CLAY HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO WE ARE NEUTRAL
ON THIS AUDIT REQUEST WE
UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE FOR
HAVING ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
REGARDING THE OPERATIONS OF OUR
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
AND WE WELCOME THE REVIEW WE
FEEL THAT WE'VE BEEN RUNNING
THE PROGRAM WITH INTEGRITY AND
PROVIDING BETTER AIR QUALITY
FOR THE CITIZENS OR THE
RESIDENTS OF SAN DIEGO AS BOTH
THE SPONSORS AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA MENTIONED WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLAPPER LEAVE
WITH SOME ON. THE DETAILS OF
FOUR TWENTY THREE WHICH WOULD
BASICALLY REMAKE THE
COMPOSITION OF THE AIR DISTRICT
TO INCLUDE CITIES AND OTHER
CITIZENS WITH WITHIN THE COUNTY
AND WITH THAT I'D WE'RE JUST
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU FOR SHARE THAT. ANY
OTHER AFFECTED AGENCIES HEARING
INSANE NINE WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT AS OR
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
AGENDA ITEM. GEN ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. SYRIAN SAYING MAN. WE
WILL MOVED TO VOTE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CLOTHES SOMEONE NUMBER
GLORIA IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
MISTER ROTH IT'S BEEN SECOND IN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO WITH
THAT. MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE
ATER REQUEST NUMBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DASH ONE
TWENTY SEVEN SAN DIEGO AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI SOUTH
HIGH EARNER WERE ABOUT. MAYES
PATTERSON PATTERSON NOW. RUBIO
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL NOW
WHAT. CENTER ROTH ROTH I ORDERS.
GORGEOUS NOW GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG. MONNING MONNING
AYE MORLOCK MOORLACH NOW WIENER
WIENER AYE. WALLY THAT MOTION
ON CALL. OKAY AT THIS TIME WE
WILL MOVE TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
THIS IS TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
DASH ONE TWO ONE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE OVERSIGHT OF THE
PET LOVERS SPECIALIZED LICENSE
PLATE PROGRAM. MR QUIRK WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN. THANK
YOU JUST JUST A MOMENT
. WELL
GOOD MORNING CHAIR SENATORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OUR AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
MY REQUEST TO HAVE THE STATE
AUDITOR EXPLORE THE PET LOVERS
SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATE FONT.
ALL I MAKE REQUESTING ON A TREE
VIEW HOW THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
FUNCTIONING TO DATE WITH A
FOCUS ON PROVIDING PUBLIC
ASSURANCE. THAT THERE'S BEEN A
FAIR PROCESS FOR AWARDING FUNDS.
THE ITEMS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE SCOPE AND OBJECTIVES
STRIVE TO IDENTIFY THE VARIOUS
ASPECTS OF HOW THE PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED. A CURRENT
STATEMENT OF FUNDS AVAILABLE
AND WARRANTED AND THE PROCESS
BY WHICH THESE FUNDS ARE
DETERMINED. NOW I DID HAVE A
VERY HELPFUL MEETING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT YESTERDAY AND MANY
OF MY QUESTIONS WERE ANSWERED.
BUT THEY RAISE MANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE WHOLE PROCESS. I WILL
SAY THAT IN LOOKING AT THEY
SHOWED ME WHAT THE AWARDS WERE
THEY SEEM TO GO TO QUITE
REPUTABLE ORGANIZATIONS THAT'S
GOOD. BUT WE DO NOT KNOW
FRANKLY ANYTHING ABOUT HOW
THESE WERE DETERMINED EVEN NOW.
OF MAJOR REASON FOR THIS IS
THAT THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THAT MAKE THIS
DISPOSITION OF FUNDS IS SECRET.
AND FURTHER THEIR DELIBERATIONS
ARE SECRET. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHAT'S THE BIG DEAL.
ALL OF YOU HAVE PROBABLY SERVED
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHERE YOU
HAD APPOINTED GROUPS CITIZEN
VOLUNTEERS WHO ARE MAKING
DECISIONS WITH REGARD TO
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS FOR
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF GIVING
AWAY OF FEDERAL MONEY DECIDING
WHICH NONPROFIT TO WOULD GO TO
A PROPER PROCESS MOST LIKE
THIS. WITH LARGE AMOUNTS OF
MONEY ALWAYS HAD PLENTY OF
VOLUNTEERS ALWAYS HAD A PUBLIC
PROCESS. AND I THINK THAT'S ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS TO
LOOK AT BECAUSE THE REASON WE
WERE GIVEN FOR THIS IS WE DO
THIS THROUGHOUT THE DEPARTMENT
AT STANDARD FURTHER IT'S
STANDARD THEY SAID IN MARCH OF
THE STATE GOVERNMENT I REALLY
THINK THIS HAS TO BE UNDERSTOOD
EXTREMELY WELL IN IT HAS. RANMA
IF THIS IS TRUE THAT THIS IS
SOME STANDARD PROCEDURE THAT IS
RAMIFICATIONS THROUGHOUT STATE
GOVERNMENT SO THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ASPECT OF
THE AUDIT. A SECOND I DID GET
AGAIN THE ANSWERS TO MOST OF MY
QUESTIONS YESTERDAY BUT. THESE
THINGS NEED TO BE AVAILABLE AND
TO THE PUBLIC AND THERE SIMPLY
WASN'T A GOOD PROCESS FOR THAT
SO WE HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THEIR PROCESS SEES. THE THIRD
POINT HERE IS THAT THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY CALLED FOR
COLLABORATION. AND WHAT THIS
COLLABORATION MEANS DOES IT
MEAN THAT YOU EXCHANGE EMAILS
AND WITH SOMEONE OR DOES IT
MEAN THAT YOU TAKE NOTE OF WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING. SO AGAIN
TALKING ABOUT COLLABORATION I
THINK THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND AGAIN OF
STATEWIDE ISSUE BECAUSE WE ARE
ALL WAYS LOOKING FOR PUBLIC
INPUT IN HOW WE DO THIS. SO I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM BUT I WOULD SAY
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO THE
SECRECY OF HOW THE FUNDS ARE
GIVEN. THAT IS I THINK
SOMETHING THAT WOULD REALLY
NEEDS TO BE TAKEN TO A VERY
CAREFUL LOOK AT. SO I REQUEST
BY RESPECTFULLY PRESS THE
COMMITTEE APPROVE THIS WITH THE
TIMING PRIORITIZATION SO THAT
THE RESULTS MAY BE AVAILABLE
SHOULD ADDITIONAL CLARIFYING
LEGISLATION BE NEEDED NEXT YEAR.
AND I THINK THAT WELL AGAIN WE
REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT THE
SECRECY OF HOW THESE FUNDS ARE
GIVEN AND WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT THE IS
JUDY MANN CRUCERO FOUNDER AND
CEO AND PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL
COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION THE
SPONSORING ORGANIZATION FOR THE
PET LOVERS LICENSE PLATE. DR
ANALLY FUSE ME ALLEN THREE C.
DIRECTOR AND CHIEF VETERINARIAN
FOR RIVERSIDE COUNTY ANIMAL
SERVICES AND THEN I REALLY WANT
TO THANK VERY MUCH OF BILL
GATES FOR BEING HERE HE'S THE
CHIEF CONSULTANT WITH SENATE
BUSINESS AND- PROFESSIONS AND
HE'S HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU. ADDRESS QUIRK WILL GO
AHEAD IN ALLOW YOUR ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY. YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SO GOOD MORNING
I'M JUDY MAN CREW SO FROM
LAGUNA BEACH CALIFORNIA I
ACTUALLY HAVE THREE NON PROFITS
AND ONE CAME UP OUT OF THIS.
PROCESS THAT WE THAT DR DREW
SEASON I STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT AND TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS A PET
OVERPOPULATION CRISIS AND WE
KILL HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ANIMALS IN OUR SHELTERS EVERY
YEAR AND THESE ARE TAX PAYER
DOLLARS SO IT'S A MORAL DEFICIT
IT'S A FINANCIAL DEFICIT. AND
SO ALLEN DR DREW SEASON I AND
OTHERS AROUND THE STATE SAID WE
NEED A FUNDING MECHANISM THAT
IS NOT FROM THE GOVERNMENT BUT
A PUBLIC PRIVATE PROGRAM THEY
CAN BE A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
MECHANISM AND THAT THIS FUNDING
MECHANISM BE 1100% TRANSPARENT.
TO THE PUBLICTO THE GOVERNMENT
TO EVERYBODY THAT PUTS MONEY IN
IT SO THE FIRST THING WE DID IS
WE WENT TO THE BMB AND WE
APPROACH THEM TO DO A LICENSE
PLATE PROGRAM THEY SAID YES.
WELL A LICENSE PLATE PROGRAM
HAD IT BEEN IN PLACE SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE BECAUSE OF
A LAWSUIT. SO THEN WE WENT TO
SENATOR PADILLA AT THAT TIME
WHO THOUGHT HE NEEDED TO DO
LEGISLATION TO HELP US BUT THEN
THE DMV SAID NO. NO ALL THAT
THIS NONPROFIT HAS TO DO IS
THEY NEED A SPONSORING AGENCY
THEY HAVE TO GET THEIR ARTWORK
APPROVED AND PIERCE BROSNAN WHO
IS A FRIEND DID THE ARTWORK FAR
US THIS IS HIS CAT ANGEL BABY
AND NOT SHILOH. AND HE HAS
GIVEN US THAT OUR WORK IN
PERPETUITY FOR THE PLATE TO MY
TO OUR NINE ARE NONPROFIT. AND
THE THIRD THING THAT WE HAD TO
DO WAS ACCUMULATES. SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED PRE ORDERS THAT
THEN WE WOULD TURN ALL. ALL
THIS OVER TO THE DMV SO ONE OF
MY BOARD MEMBERS DR GARY
MICHAEL SAN PUT IN TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR US TO
START. MARKETING MEANING ON THE
WORD OUT. TO MY WITNESS. I
DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY TO
GO TO THE HISTORY OF ALL OF
THIS. I THINK YOU WOULD BE I
THINK THE COMMITTEE WOULD BE
BETTER SERVED IF YOU SIMPLY
TALKED ABOUT YOUR INTERACTIONS
WITH CDFA. ANTIOCH RESIDENTS
OKAY I THINK YES IN THE CHAIR
APPROVALS. OKAY THANK OKAY THEN
I'LL FLY FORWARD SO WE GAVE THE
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND AT THAT TIME WE
WERE RECEIVING REPORTS ON HOW
MUCH MONEY WAS IN HOW MANY
PLATES WERE SOLD. SO THAT THOSE
REPORTS HAVE COMPLETELY STOPPED
WE DID A BILL WITH US SENATOR
NEWMAN THAT SAID THAT OF THAT
THE- NONPROFIT US WOULD. WORK
WITH THE CDFA AND WE WERE
TRANSFERRED TO THEM IN ORDER TO
GET TO GET THIS MONEY OUT SO
BOTTOM LINE IS THE REPORTS
STOPPED THE MONEY YOU GOT. WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY
THERE'S BEEN OF THE MONEY HAS
BEEN DISTRIBUTED IN SECRET WHEN
IT WOULDN'T WOULDN'T WRITTEN A
LAW THAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE A
PART OF OUR NON PROFIT TO BE A
PART OF IT. AND THE AND THEY
USED A SECRET PANEL AND A
SECRET PROCESS AND WE WANT THIS
ALL TO STOP THIS IS THE-
CALIFORNIANS MONEY. WE MADE A
PROMISE TO THEM THAT IT WAS
GOING TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO SPAY AND NEUTER PROVIDERS TO
SAVE AN ANIMAL'S LIVES THIS IS
NOT SOMEBODY SECRET. PROJECT SO
PLEASE HELP US TODAY. THANK YOU
GETTING BACK ON TRACK. THANK
YOU. ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY WAS
WORK YES PLEASE YES SIR MR
CHAIR MEMBERS DOCTOR ALLEN
JERSEYS. I NEED TO PREEMPT MY
DISCUSSIONS HERE WERE SAYING I
AM NOT REPRESENTING THE COUNTY
RIVERSIDE TODAY I AM HOWEVER
THE DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
VETERINARIAN FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF ANIMAL SERVICES FOR THE
COUNTY WE SERVE MISTER ROSS AND
MAYES DISTRICTS. AS JUDY SAID
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL SINCE ITS INCEPTION. I
AM A TECHNICAL ADVISER TO IT
OUR DEPARTMENT A SPACE AND
DAUGHTERS AN AVERAGE OF FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOGS AND CATS EVERY
YEAR. SO WE ARE A MAJOR PLAYER
IN THE COUNTY OF RIVERSIDE
PROVIDING THESE SERVICES. OVER
THE YEARS PEOPLE HAVE ACTUALLY
ASKED ME WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THE LICENSE PLATE AND.
UNFORTUNATELY UP UNTIL RECENTLY
I HAD TO SAY WELL WE DON'T KNOW
OR NOTHING'S HAPPENING IT'S-
WHAT IT OR ASIAN IT IS TODAY
WHO WILL CHANGE TOMORROW AND
THE QUESTION ALWAYS BECOMES WHY
SHOULD WE PURCHASE A LICENSE
PLATE IF IT GOES FOR SPAY AND
NEUTER WILL. WAIT WHERE ARE THE
RESULTS. IT'S ONLY. THIS YEAR
THAT. SOME FUNDING HAS BEEN
DISPERSED AND I HAVE ALSO
HEARD. CURRENTLY OF FROM MINOR
PROVIDERS A SPAN NEW SERVICES
IN THE COUNTY AND FROM
INDIVIDUALS AGAIN WHO THINK
ABOUT GETTING THEIR ANIMAL
SPAYED OR NEUTERED UP
POTENTIALLY PURCHASING A
LICENSE PLATE QUESTIONING. HOW
DID THESE MONIES WE KNOW THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY GOT SOME ABOUT
HOW DO I GET THESE MONIES AND I
HAVE LOW'S TO BE ABLE TO
EXPLAIN TO THEM. THE PROCESS I
SAY CDFA OF PROVIDES THE
MECHANISM BUT. WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS PROCESS
WORKS I'M CERTAINLY GRATEFUL
THE CDFA OVER THE YEARS WE'VE
WE'VE. BEEN THE RECIPIENT OF
MANY GRANTS FROM THEM INCLUDING
SO YOU'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THE PROCEDURE AND ASKING FOR
TRANSPARENT CORRECT. THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO THE STATE HONORS
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK INDICATED THIS IS AN
AUDIT OF THE PET LOVER
SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATE PLAY
PROGRAM. REALLY START LOOKING
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND HIS FIRST
OBJECTIVE WE HAVE IN OUR
PROPOSAL IS. A REALLY LOOKING
AT THE PROCESS THAT FOOD NICK
USES TO AWARD GRANTS AND
LOOKING AT HOW MUCH FUNDING IS
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE IN THE
PROGRAM. HOW MUCH FUNDING HAS
BEEN GENERATED SINCE THE
PROGRAM BEGAN BACK IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND THEN HOW MUCH OF
THOSE MONIES ARE SPENT ON
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS MARKETING
PROMOTIONAL ACTIVITIES. VERSES
GRANTS THAT ARE GETTING OUT TO
THE COMMUNITIES TO THAT TO THE
CLINICS AND FACILITIES THAT ARE
PROVIDING THE SERVICES SO
REALLY LOOKING AT SOME FUNDING.
BUT ALSO LOOKING AT THE PROCESS
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE WITNESSES
AND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOOKING
AT THE PROCESS THAT FOOD NAG
USES TO. ASSESS GRANT
APPLICATIONS AND THEIR DECISION
MAKING PROCESS WITH RESPECT TO
DENYING A GRANT OR APPROVING A
GRANT THE LENGTH OF TIME IT
TAKES FOR THAT PROCESS TO TAKE
PLACE. AGAIN LOOKING AT THE
EAST ANY STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
ANY OTHER REQUIREMENTS THAT
FOOD NAG SUPPOSED TO FOLLOW SO
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
FOLLOWING THE PROPER PROTOCOLS.
THE OTHER A COUPLE OF
OBJECTIVES LOOKING AT
COLLABORATION WITH NONPROFIT
ENTITIES AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE PROGRAM IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED. TO THE TO THE MOST
EFFECTIVE EXTENT POSSIBLE ARE
THEY CONTINUING TO COLLABORATE
WITH THE NON PROFITS TO
IDENTIFY AREAS OF IMPROVEMENT
FOR THE PARTICULAR PROGRAM. SO
THERE'S A COUPLE OF OBJECTIVES
RELATED TO COLLABORATION A
MAJOR OBJECTIVE RELATED TO
LOOKING AT THE PROCESS FOR
ASSESSING GRANT APPLICATIONS
AWARDING THEM OR DENYING THEM
AND CERTAINLY LOOKING OUT THE
FUNDING. SINCE INCEPTION WHICH
WAS BACK IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
RELATIVELY SMALL LOT AT
NINETEEN HUNDRED HOURS IT'LL
TAKE US A LITTLE LESS THAN FIVE
MONTHS TO COMPLETE THE WORK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU ATWATER LET ME ASK IF
BECAUSE THIS WAS HANDED OUT TO
US FROM CDFA AND I BELIEVE THEY
GAVE IT TO MR QUIRK OF YOU. YES
WE'VE GOT THAT YES DO. RAIN IT
DOES ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS WE'VE HAD. UP THE
PROCESS QUESTION PARTICULARLY
THE BUSINESS OF A SECRET
COMMITTEE. IS ASKING IF THE
AUDITOR HAD RECEIVED IT AND
SINGLE OKAY. NO I HAVE NOT SEEN
THAT LETTER MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU. BUT THIS TIME WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO WE AFFECTED AGENCIES.
IT OF THE AFFECTED AGENCIES IF
WE HAVE OKAY WITH. YES PLEASE
YOU CAN COME HERE YES PLEASE
.
GOOD MORNING MORNING SO IS THAT
CHAIR OF VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
RACHEL BRIAN I'M THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE WITH ME IS
CRYSTAL MYERS SHE'S OUR BRANCH
CHIEF OF THE OFFICE OF GRANTS
ADMINISTRATION AT CDFA AT CFA
WAS DESIGNATED AS THE AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PET LOVER
SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATE
PROGRAM UPON GOVERNOR BROWN'S
APPROVAL OF SENATE BILL SIX
SEVEN THREE OCTOBER FOURTEENTH
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. STATE LAW
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES TO DEPOSIT THE
FEES FOR ISSUANCE RENEWAL OR
TRANSFER UP THE SPECIALIZED
LICENSE PLATE MINUS THEIR COST.
INTO THE PLATE FUND MONIES IN
THE FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO CDFA. THE FAA
RECEIVED BUDGET AUTHORITY FROM
THE LEGISLATURE EFFECTIVE JULY
ONE TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
ADMINISTER THE LICENSE PLATE
PROGRAM. AT AN ANNUAL LEVEL OF
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THREE YEARS FROM
THE FUND. OF THIS AMOUNT UP TO
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND IS
ALLOCATED FROM SEA TO FACE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THIS WAS
LAID OUT IN R. B. C. P. PROCESS
IN DURING THE PROCESS. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CDFA SALICYLATE
SOLICITED PROPOSALS AND
ANNOUNCED AWARDS BETWEEN
JANUARY MAY OF TWENTY NINETEEN
THIS YEAR. GRANT AGREEMENTS
WITH ELEVEN RECIPIENTS WERE
EXECUTED BETWEEN JUNE AND
AUGUST TWENTY NINETEEN TOTALING
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ALL ELEVEN
WERE ORGANISED TO ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE PREVIOUSLY OR
CURRENTLY PROVIDED LOW COST
KNOWS NO COST STERILIZATION
SEVEN WENT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
IDENTIFIED AS PROVIDING
SERVICES TO UNDERSERVED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. THE TOTAL
VALUE OF REVENUE COLLECTED BY
THE DMV. INTO A SPECIALIZED
LICENSE PLATE FIND WAS AFFECT
EFFECTIVE JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
NINETEEN WAS ONE MILLION SIX
HUNDRED AND 790-009-0060 SEVEN
DOLLARS AND ONE CENT. EFFECTIVE
AUGUST TWENTY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN THE BALANCE OF THE
FUND FOR THE PET LOVERS LICENSE
PLATE WAS ONE MILLION
500-003-0030 SEVEN DOLLARS.
AFFECTED TODAY CFA HAS BEEN
INVOICED FOR A TOTAL OF
800-040-0405 DOLLARS. FIRST
QUARTER INVOICES ARE DO HERE AT
THE END OF AUGUST STILL
CONTINUE TO ROLL AND AFTER THAT
SO THIS IS A FAIRLY NEW PROCESS
FOR US. AND WE JUST GOT IT OFF
THE GROUND IN THE LAST YEAR. I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE
ADDITIONALLY THAT FROM JULY
FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN THROUGH
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY NINETEEN.
FORTY ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO DOLLARS
AND TWELVE CENTS HAS BEEN
EXPENDED FOR ADMINISTRATION.
ADDITIONALLY 320-008-0090 SEVEN
DOLLARS ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING.
HAS BEEN SET ASIDE TO PROMOTE
THE LICENSE PLATE THREE IN
CERTAIN THE DMV'S RENEWAL
NOTICE FOR FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY. CFA IS VERY PROUD OF
THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE TO BE
ABLE TO STAND UP THIS PROGRAM
AND MEET OUR LEGISLATIVE
MANDATE. AND THIS AMOUNT OF
TIME TO GET THESE FUNDS OUT TO
ELIGIBLE NONPROFITS AND
INEFFICIENT AND COLLABORATIVE
MANNER WE DID ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS COMMUNICATE WITH
SOCIAL COMPASSIONATE
LEGISLATION WE HELD A MEETING
AND A WEAPON ARE FOR THEIR
BENEFIT IN DECEMBER TO COLLECT
THEIR INPUT. ON THE R. F. P.
PROCESS AS WE WERE DEVELOPING
IT WE GOT A DRAFT OF THE R. F.
P. FROM THAT THAT MEDICARE
MEDICAL BOARD WHO REGION WE
ACTUALLY HAD THE PROGRAM AND
WAS UNFORTUNATELY NOT ABLE TO
GET STAND UP AND GET THE FUNDS
OUT. SO WE GOT THAT DROP I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT DRAFT
ACTUALLY HAD INPUT AND WAS
ACTUALLY ORIGINALLY DEVELOPED
BY SOCIAL COMPASSIONATE
LEGISLATION SO RIGHT OFF THE
BAT GETTING THE R. F. P. THAT
THEY HELPED DEVELOP AS THE
DRAFT. GETTING THEIR INPUT IN
THE WEAPON ARE AND MEETING WITH
THE STAKE HOLDERS THAT YOU SAW
HERE AT THE TABLE TODAY ON
DECEMBER FOURTH AND THEN
FURTHER COLLABORATION WHEN WE
ANNOUNCED THE AWARDS ALL OF OUR
PROCESS HAS BEEN. POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE THROUGH OUR PUBLIC
AFFAIRS TEAMS SO WHEN WE PUSH
OUT A NOTICE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE R. F. P. WHEN WE PUSHED
OUT A PUBLIC NOTICE FOR
APPLICANTS TO APPLY TO BE
TECHNICAL OUR VIEWERS. OF THE
GRANTS THAT WE RECEIVED AND
THEN ALONG WITH THE OBVIOUSLY
NOTICE OF WHEN THE GRANTS WENT
OUT WE ACTUALLY DID THAT NOTICE
OF WHEN THE GRANTS WHEN OUT. IN
COLLABORATION WITH SOCIAL
COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION WE
DIDN'T DO A JOINT PRESS RELEASE
BUT WE EACH DID OUR OWN ONE WE
MADE THEM AWARE OF WHEN WE WERE
GOING TO BE ANNOUNCING. CFA
VERY MUCH SUPPORTS TRANSPARENCY
AND WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXAMINE THE
PROGRAM FOR POTENTIAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVEMENT
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
SECRETARY COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY BUT SHE WANTED ME TO
IMPRESS UPON YOU. THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE WORKING ON THIS THE
COMMITTEE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
WHETHER AN AUDIT IS PREMATURE
AT THIS TIME SINCE THIS PROGRAM
HAS BEEN AFFECT. FOR
APPROXIMATELY ONE YEAR AND IS
EXPENDED LESS THAN 3% OF THE
ANNUAL MOUNTS AWARDED. I THINK
ON THE OTHER END YOU CAN SAY
THAT. AN AUDIT IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT ENSURES THAT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. WE HAVE A GOOD
STRONG PROCESS IN PLACE THAT IS
TRANSPARENT AND OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC. SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
AND IT WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THIS TIME WHEN WE ASK
IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
FROM ANY AFFECTED AGENCIES.
HEARING AND SEEING NINE LET ME
TURN IT BACK TO THE DíAS OF
THE WE HAVE A QUESTION FROM
SENATOR ROTH. SIR SINCE YOU
INDICATED THAT TERM YOU RECEIVE
MOST OF THE ANSWERS TO YOUR
QUESTIONS ALBEIT. IN THE LAST
DAY OR SO AND GIVEN THE FACT
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH PUBLIC
MONEY HERE IN TERMS OF THE
EXPENSES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
AUDIT. ARE YOU ABLE TO MODIFY
IN YOUR AUDIT REQUESTED ANYWAY
WITH RESPECT TO THE ISSUES OR
QUESTIONS THAT YOU'VE AS THE
AUDITOR TO ADDRESS OF. TO FOCUS
ON THOSE ISSUES OR QUESTIONS OF
WITH RESPECT TO WHICH YOU DID
NOT RECEIVE ANSWERS. YET SO
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK
THE DEPUTY SECRETARY AND THE
BRANCH CHIEF. OF THEY REALLY
DID A THOROUGH JOB OF ANSWERING
QUESTIONS LIKE HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY'RE WELL AS HOW MUCH WAS
GIVEN OUT. HOW MUCH WAS USED IN
ADMINISTRATION. ARE THERE TO
ASPECTS OF THIS ONE IS MAKING
SURE THAT THAT'S EASILY
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC. AND WE
HAVE A PUBLIC MEMBER RIGHT HERE
WHO FELT SHE COULDN'T GET THAT
INFORMATION. WHO CERTAINLY
KNOWS THE SYSTEM SO. AND I HAVE
NO DOUBT THEY WILL PUT IN. A
BETTER PROCESS BUT FRANKLY THE
THING THAT BOTHERS ME THE MOST
WAS HEARING FROM THE BRANCH
CHIEF. BAD IT IS STANDARD
PROCEDURE TO HAVE A COMMITTEE
LIKE THIS BE CONFIDENTIAL SO
THAT IT WOULDN'T FEEL PRESSURE.
AND YOU KNOW. THIS IS STRANGE
AND IF IT IS STANDARD PROCEDURE
IN CDFA AND WE'LL FIND OUT IF
IT'S STANDARD PROCEDURE ACROSS
THE STATE ARM. I HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AND I THINK YOU WOULD
TO BECAUSE AGAIN WE HAVE PLENTY
OF VOLUNTEERS TO DO THIS TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL I KNOW. PEOPLE ARE
ANXIOUS TO SERVE ON COMMITTEES
LIKE THIS. ARM PARTICULARLY. I
JUST DON'T SEE HOW THAT WOULD
BE. OUR PROBLEM MAKING THAT
PUBLIC AND HAVING. AND HAVING
MEETINGS WHERE IT THE PROCESS
IS. SHOWN TO THE PUBLIC SO I
THINK THAT'S PROBABLY MY
BIGGEST CONCERN ARM. WELL I'M
JUST I'M LISTEN I'M SUPPORT OF
THE AUDIT I JUST NOTICED THAT
THERE RIGHT WELL THERE TWELVE
ISSUES OR QUESTIONS HERE AND
YOU INDICATED THAT. YOU HAD
ANSWERS TO SOME OF THEM AND I
WAS JUST WONDERING RIGHT HOW
MANY OF THE TWELVE WE CAN CROSS
OFF THE LIST WE CAN SAY THE
AUDITOR'S SOME TIME AND SAVE
SOME MONEY YEAH I THINK YOU WE
CAN IN PARTICULAR THAT THE
DOLLARS ARE THERE. ANDMUCH
OTHER INFORMATION IS THERE SO
MAYBE WE CAN SAVE SOME MONEY ON
THE AUDIT I AGREE I THINK THAT
THE LARGER QUESTION IS AS THE
AUDITOR'S SAID HIS PROCESS. I
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PROCESS FOR THE COMMITTEE
ARE WE CAN TALK ABOUT OTHER
ISSUES AS WELL NOW THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU CENTER AND I
WOULD JUST IMAGINE SINCE SOME
OF THE INFORMATIONS ALREADY
PRESENTED IT WOULD TAKE LESS
STAFF TIME TO. TO GET THESE
ANSWERS WHICH IN EFFECT WOULD
LOWER THE COST PROBABLY OF THE
ADDED MAYBE THE STAFF HOURS
NEEDED. CERTAINLY MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS IT WOULD I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY I JUST SEEING THE
LETTER NOW AND THERE IS
INFORMATION A LETTER WHAT I
WOULD EXPECT MY STAFF TO DO IS.
GO INTO THE FINANCIAL RECORDS
TO VERIFY. WHAT THEY'RE
ASSERTING IN THE LETTER BUT IF
IT'S- IN FACT CORRECTED THAT IS
GOING TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
TIME IT WOULD TAKE MY STAFF TO.
TO COMPLETE CERTAIN OBJECTIVES
ABSOLUTELY YEAH AND I'LL ALSO
ADD. THAT THE DEPUTY SECRETARY
IN BRANCH CHIEF BROUGHT. A
WHOLE FOLDER TO ME WHICH I
BELIEVE. THEY WILL BE GIVING TO
YOU SHORTLY. AND IT IT REALLY
DOES ANSWER A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS. I THINK THE MAIN
QUESTION HERE IS PROCESS RIGHT
NOW. AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT I'D
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT I HEARD IN THE
TESTIMONY AS WELL AS A
TRANSPARENCY IN THE PROCEDURES
IN PLACE FOR AYE. HOW THIS IS
ACTUALLY DONE IMPLEMENTED AND I
KNOW THE PROGRAM'S FAIRLY.
FAIRLY NEO I EVER SINCE THE
NEWMAN LEGISLATION AS WELL SO.
OKAY WITH THAT LET ME ASK
THERE'S ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FROM THE DíAS. SENATOR MORLOCK
THE WOMAN SAID HER MONEY.
MISTER CHAIR BACK TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE HELD A HEARING WITH
THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE AND WE LOOKED
AT THE VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS
AND MONEY THAT WAS GOING BY THE
CHECK OFF ON THE FORM FIVE
FORTY AND- AND HOW THE
CONTROLLER WAS SORT OF HOLDING
ON TO THAT MONEY. I SEE THAT AS
THE ISSUE HERE I THOUGHT MAYBE
THE CONTROLLER COULD PROVIDE
SOME MORE DETAILS AND IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT. THE ISSUE IS JUST
HOW ARE THE NONPROFIT SELECTED
AND HOW'S THE MONEY
DISTRIBUTED. AND I'M I'M
WONDERING. HOW MANY.
SPECIALIZED PLATES DO WE STILL
HAVE BETTER. RECEIVING FUNDS
AND SHOULD WE TAKE A HOLISTIC
LOOK TO SEE. WHAT'S THE PROCESS
FOR ALL OF THEM INSTEAD OF JUST
ONE SO WE CAN. MAKE SURE WE
HAVE YOU KNOW ABOUT A PUT AN
APPROPRIATE. YOU KNOW
TRANSPARENT RESPONSIBLE MANNER
FOR GRANTING FUNDS TO ALL
NONPROFIT CENTER BENEFITING
FROM THIS PROGRAM. AND I'M I'M
JUST WONDERING ALSO WITH
PERHAPS WE SHOULD REQUIRE MORE
REPORTING TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
AN ANNUAL REPORT ON WHERE'S
THAT MONEY COMING. FROM AND HOW
MUCH IS IT WHERE'S IT GOING IN
I DON'T KNOW IF SPENDING TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON AUDIT FOR SOMETHING
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO GENERATE.
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
YEARS. I AFFECTED BUT I'D- LIKE
TO GET THE WHOLE THING FIX NOT
JUST. ONE SPECIFIC PLAY AND I
THINK WHAT WE'RE IF YOU WANTED
TO AUDIT ALL OF THEM THAT WOULD
BE A LOT MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND. I THINK IF WE
CAN JUST AUDIT WINE. AND THEN
YOU AND I CAN CO AUTHOR OF
BAIL. TO TAKE TO SEE WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THERE. AND START A
PROCESS. AS HE SAID
PARTICULARLY THE QUESTION FOR
ME IS THE SELECTION OF THE
COMMITTEES DOES THAT NEED
REALLY NEED TO BE CONFIDENTIAL
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE'LL
FIND OUT IN THE OFFICE. DID
THEIR DELIBERATIONS NEED TO BE
CONFIDENTIAL. AGAIN IF THIS IS
A NORMAL PRACTICE IN THE STATE.
THAT I THINK THAT THIS IS A
STATE WIDE ISSUE WHEN YOU AND I
CAN WORK ON IT TOGETHER I'D BE
HONORED SO IMMIGRANT QUIRK.
BECAUSE I THINK IF WE COULD
NARROW IT TO THIS SPECIFIC
ISSUE I THINK WE OUGHT TO BE.
RATHER SIMPLE FOR ALL THE PLATE.
A FULL LOOK GO AHEAD. IN ORDER
TO PLACE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
JUST TO. INFORM MEMBERS WE
ACTUALLY DID AN AUDIT ON THE
SPECIAL INTERESTS LICENSE PLATE
PROGRAM AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES WE DID THE
ORIGINAL AUDIT AND ISSUED IN
APRIL OF TWENTY THIRTEEN IT'S A
BIT OLD WE HAD ISSUES WE FELT
THAT THE STATE WAS FOR GOING
REVENUES RELATED TO THE PROGRAM
SOME OF THE EXPENDITURES WERE
NOT STE PROPERLY SUPPORTED SO
WE REALLY QUESTIONS SOME
THINGS. WE DID A SUBSEQUENT
FOLLOW UP ON IT IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN IDENTIFIED THERE ARE
STILL SOME ISSUES WITH RESPECT
TO HOW THE ENVY WAS MANAGING
THE PROGRAM WE HAVE NOT BEEN
BACK SINCE THEN SO WE COULD
EITHER DO A FOLLOW UP ON IT IF
WE HAVE RESOURCES AVAILABLE WE
COULD CERTAINLY DO THAT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND GET YOU
INFORMATION. PERHAPS BY EARLY
NEXT YEAR EASILY I WOULD THINK
THIS PARTICULAR JUST TO FOLLOW
UP ON WHAT WE DID OR IF MEMBERS
ARE INTERESTED IN REQUESTING A
DIFFERENT AUDIT WE CERTAINLY
WOULD BE. HAPPY TO DO ANY WORK
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE US
TO DO JUST WANTED TO LET THE
MEMBERS NOW. THANK YOU FOR
SHAPE THAT I BELIEVE THERE SOME
AVENUES ARE TO PURSUE SIR
MORLOCK OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROCEDURES
OF THE TRANSPARENCIES IN PLACE
FOR ALL OF MY THINK IS WHERE
YOU WERE HEADED. MISTER PARKS
LOOKING AT ONE SPECIALIZED.
PLATE RIGHT NOW THE OTHERS
THAT'S MORE CAN PASS A MAYBE.
MAYBE FROM THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THIS OUT OF MOVES FORWARD WE
CAN USE THAT AS WELL. AT TWO
AND FOUR MAYBE FUTURE
LEGISLATION. WELL I WOULD THINK
A FOLLOW UP ON IT WOULD. WOULD
BE. PREFERABLE AND PROBABLY.
MORE COST EFFECTIVE AND
PROBABLY. GETS TO WHERE WE ALL
WANT TO BE. RIGHT AND WE HAVE
JUST SO THE MEMBERS UNDERSTAND
WE DO HAVE STATUTORY AUTHORITY
TO CONDUCT FOLLOW UP WORK SO
WE- WE'VE DONE ONE FOLLOW UP
SPENT A LITTLE WHILE WE CAN GET
BACK IN THERE AND DO SOME MORE
WORK. THANK AND THEN IF THAT
DOESN'T WORK AND- THE
ASSEMBLYMAN AND I WILL. JOINT
AUTHOR A BILL TO GET BETTER
REPORTING OUT OF. C. F. CDFA.
WELL IT'S REALLY ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE INVOLVED.
VIDEO AND I MEAN IT'S NOT JUST
LICENSE PLATE PROGRAMS. WE HAD
IF IT IS TRUE. THAT IT'S A
STANDARD. I HAVE KEEP THEM. THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LIKE
THIS SECRET I AND ALSO THE
DELIBERATIONS I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING YOU KNOW GOES WAY
BEYOND LICENSE PLATES SO I
THINK WE REALLY NEED IF WE CAN
UNDERSTAND THIS PROGRAM AND
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE CONDITIONS
ARE JUSTIFIED THEN WE COULD
START LOOKING AT THE MORE
GENERAL PROGRAM WHICH GOES WAY
BEYOND LICENSE BITES YEAH I
AGREE WITH THAT BECAUSE IT
ALSO. IMPACTS HE'S VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION YEAH ABSOLUTE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE MONEY
JUST LANGUISHES THE STATE
CONTROLLER'S DOING NOTHING WITH
THEM SO I THINK THAT'S THE BIG
ISSUES THAT GET SOME UNIFORMITY
AND- GET SOME GOOD REPORTING. I
GET IT. THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL
MOVE SENATOR MONEY PLEASE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I APPRECIATE
THIS DIALOGUE. I CAN WANT TO
COME BACK TO THE QUESTION OF
SENATOR ROTH THOUGH IT SEEMS IN
LIGHT OF SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED. A BIT DATED YESTERDAY
HERE FEW DAYS AGO. MAYBE THIS
QUESTION FOR THE AUDITOR. GIVEN
THE INFORMATION THAT'S
AVAILABLE WITH THAT CONFORM OR
OR FOR FURTHER FOCUS THE WORK
OF THE AUDITOR TO THE
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS OR SOME
OF THE PROCESS QUESTIONS THAT
MIGHT NECESSARILY INVOLVE.
LOOKING IT. CDOS PROTOCOLS IN
IN THISINSTANCE WITH RESPECT
TO CDFA BUT THAT THERE MIGHT BE
OF. A LEARNING CURVE FROM THE
AUDIT ON THIS PROGRAM THE COULD
ALSO INFORM SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS. ASKED BY SENATOR
MORLOCK. CERTAINLY MISSED A
CENTER MINING IT IT WOULD SAVE
US SOME TIME I MEAN I THINK THE
COMMITTEE HAS TO DECIDE I DON'T
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE
COMMITTEE IS SUGGESTING THAT
THE AUDIT ANALYSIS BE MODIFIED
AND THERE ARE ROUTE COMMITTEE
RULES WITH RESPECT TO THAT BUT
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS. BASED
ON THE QUICK REVIEW OF THIS
LETTER IT WILL CERTAINLY SAVE
TIME AND IT WILL ALLOW US TO DO
OUR DUE DILIGENCE FOR CERTAIN
OBJECTIVES RELATED TO THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY IN THE FIND OF
THE AMOUNT HAS BEEN SPENT. I
THINK THAT WILL BE RELATIVELY
QUICK WE CAN VERIFY THAT WHAT
THEY'VE ASSERTED IS ACCURATE.
AND REALLY. FOCUS OUR ATTENTION
ON PROCESS AND PROTOCOLS
PARTICULARLY FOR. SOLICITING
GRANT APPLICATIONS AND THEN THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS WITH
RESPECT TO APPROVING A GRANT OR
DENYING A GRANT SO WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO FOCUS ON THAT. THANK
YOU THAT'S HELPFUL TO ME IN
MISTER TRAINER STAND TO DO A
FORMAL AMENDMENT OF THE AUDIT
REQUIRE CERTAIN PROCEDURES BUT-
I THINK THAT REASSURANCE. FROM
THE AUDITOR THAT. THEY'VE DONE
THIS BEORE AND THEY WILL.
STREAMLINED WHERE INFORMATION'S
AVAILABLE AND- CONCENTRATE
RESOURCES. ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE STILL
OUTSTANDING SO THANK YOU. THANK
SENATOR WHAT THAT. YET ON MR
MUNNINGS POINT JUST JUST JUST
ONE POINT OF CLARIFICATION I DO
APOLOGIZE THAT THESE WERE NOT
GIVEN TO THE STATE AUDITOR WE
WERE MADE AWARE THESE QUESTIONS
FOR THE FIRST TIME LAST MONDAY
SO WE WERE PULLING THIS
INFORMATION TOGETHER WE WANT TO
MAKE IT A PRIORITY TO MEET WITH
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIRST WHICH
WE FINALLY DID YESTERDAY I
ACTUALLY WASN'T AWARE OF THE
PROCESS THAT WAS REALLY JUST ME
BEING ABLE TO REACH OUT TO THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE AT THAT
WAS. APPROPRIATE OR NOT THIS IS
OUR FIRST TIME GOING THROUGH
THIS FOR ME SO THAT WAS JUST A
LEARNING CURVE APOLOGIES AND
WE'VE TRIED OUR BEST OF COURSE
SUPPOSE ALTOGETHER BUT THE DATE
OF THE LETTER OF COURSE IS
YESTERDAY BUT WE RECEIVE THESE
QUESTIONS FOR THE FIRST TIME
AND WERE MADE AWARE OF THEM.
WHEN WE RECEIVED THE AUDIT
ANNOUNCEMENTS. APPRECIATE THAT
CLARIFICATION AN APPLAUD. THE
EFFORTS THAT RESULTED IN
GETTING THIS TO US TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT LET ME
ASK IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS ON THE
DíAS. HEARING AND SEEING NONE
OF THIS WORK WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES AGAIN I THINK THIS
IS. I THINK WE OUGHT IT IT'S
WOULD YOU LIKE A THAT THAT'S
FINE. I GOTTA ASK IF THERE'S
PUBLIC CONVERSE ON THIS JOURNEY
PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE IF YOU
COULD STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION ARE COUNTY RESIDE
I CAN MORNING MISTER CHAIR
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL FOR CESSATION
WE ARE THE ASSOCIATION PRESENT
IN CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC. AND
PRIVATE NONPROFIT SHELTER IN
COMMUNITY FEELING VERY GUILTY
TODAY FOR CFA BECAUSE WE
SUPPORTED LEGISLATION MOVING IT
OVER TO THEM. FOR THE MEMBERS
ON THE I DíAS THAT THE MONEY
HAD BEEN STRANDEDTHEY GOT THE MONEY. LAST YEAR
AND GOT THE MONEY ON OR REALLY
QUICKLY I WHICH IN UNDER A YEAR
FOR STATE AGENCIES TO MOVE
MONEY OUT A SORT OF A MINUTES
LATE. FOR THIS I BODY SO WE
WOULD. SOMETHING LIKE THIS FOR
YEAR I KNOW THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO GET THE ANSWERS OUT
DOOR IF YOU WERE TO GO ONLINE
AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES STIR
IN STATE MONEY. THE IT RUNS
THE- YES THE ONE ON THE ON THE
COST OF. WHEN THERE'S A LOT OF
DETAIL THERE TAL CONSERVANCY
THERE'S NOT A- AND LICENSE
PLATE. FAR AS THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION AVAILABLE AND SO IT
SOME THE DISCUSSION THIS
MORNING HAS BEEN THE TALK ABOUT
MAYBE CONSISTENCY NOT IT'S
PROBABLY A GOOD THING BUT THEY
JUST GOT IT THEY JUST GOT THE
MONEY OUT SOME OF MY BURBANK.
SEVEN SOME OF MY MEMBERS ARE ON
THE STICKER PANEL. IS THE CASE.
IMAGINE THAT THERE WILL BE A
LOT OF. RIDLEY SO I'M- FAVOR IN
THIS POSITION AND WE THINK
MAYBE I GIVEN THE ERRANT LET
THEM PUT SOME INFORMATION OUT
THERE AND THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION. BUT THIS TIME
LET ME ASK. OR COMMENT. AND C.
NONE HAVE YET MOVED TO MY
RECORD FOR K. I THINK THE AUDIT
IS FINE THE WAY IT IS I THINK
OF THAT. PART BOB BRINGING OUT
SOME OF THE INFORMATION FORWARD
RIGHT AWAY. IT SHOULD BE MOSTLY
ON PROCESS IN PARTICULAR THIS
QUESTION OF HOW THESE.
COMMITTEES WHICH IS AGAIN I
THINK IT WAS Y. CONCERN. OP AND
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK TO DEPART
FOR ANSWERING QUESTION SO
QUICKLY BUT THE REASON THAT. I
WISH FRANKLY WHEN HE HAD TO
NOTIFY YOU SEE. SO THAT'S
REALLY THE ISSUE I A- I BELIEVE
THE DEPARTMENT WILL DO THEIR
JOB IN THE FUTURE I THINK AUDIT
WILL HELP THE PROCESS. IN A
WAYS AND SO THIS IS. TIME TO
THANK YOU. AT THE TIME A MASK
THERE'S A MOTION ON SOMEONE
MEMBER QUIRK SIDE IT. OUR
MOTION BY SENATOR ROTH TO
CANCER. RIGHT SECOND MY MISTER
VOEPEL WHAT THAT WILL GO AHEAD
AND CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE WATER REQUEST
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND AND DASH
ONE TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE OVERSIGHT OF THE
PET LOVER SPECIALIZED LICENSE
PLATE FINE. PROGRAM BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS AYE SALAS BOERNER HORVATH.
THERE WERE ABOUT THE BY MAYES.
PATTERSON PATTERSON I RUBIO
REVIEW BY VOEPEL. VOEPEL I
WOULD WHAT I CENTER ROTH. ROTH
AYE FORGES BORDERS AYE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. MORNING
MONNING AYE MOORLACH. SENATOR
WINNER SENATOR WIENER AYE. OKAY
WALL THE ROLL UP IN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS BE EVER THINK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR ATTENTION TO THIS IT'S
THIS IS BEEN VERY WELL ATTENDED
IT'S REALLY GOOD THAT YOU'RE
HERE. THANK YOU SOME ACCORDING
TO YOU VERY MUCH THANK. AT THE
SAME MOVED PASSAGE IS AGENDA
ITEM. BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO
THIS IS TWO ZERO ONE NINE DASH
ONE TWO ZERO BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING OVERSIGHT OF
PRE LICENSURE NURSING SCHOOL
PROGRAM IS MISTER VIA WHEN YOU
ARE READY TO BEGIN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING TO.
FOR THE TIME AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS REQUEST TO OUR THE
BOARD EVERY MISTER NURSES AND
THEIR OVERSIGHT ROLE IN
CONTENTION LICENSE OUT
PROGRAMS. INSURING THE
CALIFORNIA'S PROPERLY AND
ADEQUATELY TWENTY CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE WILL FORCE OF THE
FUTURE IS AN IMPORTANT ROLE FOR
BODY. THE FUNDAMENTAL
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE DATA
WHICH SHOWED. TO TRAIN MORNING
IS IN THE STATE AND THE ACTIONS
OF THE B. R. N. ACCORDING TO A
REPORT BY THE HELP OF HEALTH
FOR CENTER AT UC SAN FRANCISCO.
REGIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THERE CURRENTLY ARE
PROJECTS TO. BRING SHORTAGES IN
THE NURSING WORKFORCE THIS IS.
NO SURPRISE TO ME AS A MEMBER
OF THE BUDGETS AND HEALTH AND
HUMAN ERVICES AN AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE COMMITTEES. LIST
EVERY. OF A NOR WORKFORCE THAT
IS OVERWORKED AND STRETCHED.
THIS YEAR OVER EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND KAISER WORKERS MANY OF
THEM AS HE ARE YOU MEMBERS.
DRAG IMPART TO QUOTE DEAL WITH
MAJOR PROJECTED SHORTAGES OF
LIFE THEY DID STAFF THANK GOD.
THE HELP FOURTH REPORT A
SUPPORTS THIS AS WELL A SURVEY
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN OF NURSE
EMPLOYEE. EMPLOYERS FOUND THAT
MANY CHIEF NURSING OFFICER THE
OFFICERS ARE HAVING TROUBLE
RECRUITING NURSES AND MORE THAN
EIGHTY OF HOSPITALS REPORTED
THAT THE DEMAND FOR NURSES WAS
GREATER THAN THE AVAILABILITY
OF SUPPLY. THE REPORT ESTIMATES
THAT BY TWO. IT WILL BE SHORT
OF BY OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
NURSES IN A BASELINE SCENARIO
ESTIMATE IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
THE CURRENT RATIO OF SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT IS ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE. AND JUST AS A
POINT OF REFERENCE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE IS ONE THOUSAND THIRTY
EIGHT TIME EQUIPMENT NURSES TO
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
CLEAR SOMETHING IS NOT RIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION TO
RAPID POPULATION OF SEAT. LONG
TERM SERVICES EXPECTING OF MEDI
CAL AND THE STATE HEALTH CARE
EXCHANGE UNDER THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT HAS EXTENDED HEALTH
CARE OUR HEALTH INSURANCE TO
MORE THAN FIVE. CALIFORNIANS
WHO WERE PRE WE WITHOUT COVER.
THIS SIX COVER IN OUR- TO
ACCESS TO CARE TO THE REMAINING
THREE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
COURSE STILL UNINSURED HAS
CREATED NEW DEMAND FOR HAVE
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS OF
ALL TYPES FROM NURSES TO
DOCTORS ACCORDING TO THE BEER
AND OWN DATA IN THE TWO TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
NURSING PROGRAMS RECEIVED
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND AND FOR
QUALIFIED OP ENDS WITH ONLY.
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
AND NINETY SEVEN WE CAN. TURNER
IN PROGRAMS LET ME DO THE MATH
FOR YOU THAT IS TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND. APPLICANTS AND
POTENTIAL STUDENTS THAT WERE A
PATERNITY TO GOOD MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS DENIED THE PATHWAY TO A
MINIMUM MEANINGFUL CAREER AND
DENIED AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAINTAIN AND FORTIFY
CALIFORNIA'S HURT HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. MANY OF THESE STUDENTS
TO PRIVATE COLLEGE. HOWEVER THE
B. R. AND PREVENTS STUDENTS
FROM RECEIVING EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES BY PLACING CAPS
ON NURSING COLLEGE ENROLLMENTS.
CURRENTLY THE BEER AND CLAIMS
TO HAVE SOLE AUTHORITY TO
RESTRICT THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
THAT CAN PURSUE A DEGREE IN
NURSING THROUGH CALIFORNIA
THAT'S CONTROLLING THE MARKET
AND SUPPLY OF NURSES. NO OTHER
LICENSING BOARD HAS A PRETTY.
IMAGINE OUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF THE COMMISSION TEACHER
CREDENTIALING RESTRICTED THE
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS ENTERING
INTO A CREDENTIALING PROGRAM.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THE
MEDICAL BOARD RESTRICTED THE
AMOUNT OF DOC TRANG INTO A
MEDICAL PROFESSION AND WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF THE CALIFORNIA
BAR. THE AMOUNT OF THE TURN. IT
IS THE SAME THING THAT'S
HAPPENED HERE. IF THESE TRENDS
ARE NOT REJECTING A PROGRAM
APPLICANTS WHY ARE WE ALLOWING
THE IRAN TO RESTRICT
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS THIS AUDIT
AS THE BAND. TOOK REGARDING THE
PRACTICES OF THE BOWL. A REVIEW
OF ITS INTERNAL OPERATIONS AND
POLICY POSITIONS SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DETERMINE THE
B. R. AND MEETING PRIMARY. OF
LIGHT ENSURE. SAFETY TROLLING
THE NUMBER FOR YOU JUST TO BE.
AS A TEACHER IF I WAS
RESTRICTED. TO PURSUE MY
CREDENTIALS MY CREDENTIALS IT
WOULD BE DEVASTATING I WOULD
NOT HAVE HAD FOR CAREER FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS AND I THE- THING
LONG TERM CARE COMBINED
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS SUB ONE I
HEAR THE STORIES OVER AND OVER
AGAIN ABOUT HEALTHCARE. DOT
WOULD I SIT ON THOSE. WE TALKED
ABOUT. ACCESS TO. CARE AND NOT
ENOUGH PROVIDERS WHAT PART OF
THOSE PROVIDERS ARMED FORCES
DOCTORS ARE FANTASTIC BUT IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE SUPPORT STAFF
SUCH AS NURSES BAND HAVE ALL
THE DOCK WE WANT THE ACCESS TO
CARE IS NOT GOING TO BE. THANK
WITH ME HERE TODAY. THE POINT
IS FORMER BR AND MEMBER.
REGISTERED NURSE FROM SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WILL GUIDE AND ALLOW
YOUR ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
PLEASE GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
SALAS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JUDY
CORDLESS I HAVE BEEN A NURSE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY IT WAS MY
HONOR TO SERVE AS A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
UNDER GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
AND BROWN. I THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY IN RECENT YEARS THE
AROUND HIS EXPAND ITS AUTHORITY.
IN STATURE WHALES ON A
CREDITOR. POR MISSION. TO
LICENSE NURSES INVESTIGATE
COMPLAINTS AND ENSURE PUBLIC
SAFETY. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
BOARD HAD DECIDED. ON THE DAY
OF THE AUTHORITY TO MANAGE
ENROLLMENT SET THE SCHOOLS AND
REQUIRED APPROVAL PRIOR TO
CHANGING AND MEMBERS. AND ONE.
OMINOUS THING SO. I HAVE IN. MY
ALL REQUESTS TO GROW. TERMS BY
THE U. S. TENS FOR A FULL YEAR
AND ONE OF THE COLLEGES. THIS
ARE HAD NO THEY HAD NO
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY OR WITH
NO MEASURABLE OBJECTIVE OUR
CRITERIA OF THE DECISION MAKING.
THE BROWN HAS OPPORTUNITIES TO
CERTAINLY BRING STAKEHOLDERS
THERE ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
CONSIDER THE NATIONAL BEST
PRACTICES TO ADDRESS SERIOUS
AREAS OF CONCERN WHICH IS A
CAPACITY FOR CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS AND ENSURING THAT
ADN PROGRAMS WHICH ARE THE
CRITICAL ENTRY POINT FOR THE
PROFESSION THAT ARE PROTECTED
WHILE ALSO MEETING THE- NEED
FOR BACK LOW. NOTICES AND HALF
WAYS TO ADVANCE TING FOR
WORKING AROUND. THIS OP I HOPE
MORE LIGHT WERE SHOT ON HOW THE
BEER AND DETERMINES THREE
THINGS THAT. ACTIVITIES THAT DO
NOT NEAR THE CREDITORS AND
WASTE WATER NUYS THE BEER AND
TO MEET CURRENT AND FUTURE
NEEDED NURSING WORKFORCE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN SALAS AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
MARKETING KHôNG AND I AM AN RN
SERVING AT GREAT AND I'M ON THE
COMMITTEE HOSPITAL. I'M ON IT
SEARCH DEPARTMENT AND ON THE
HAZMAT TEAM. I'M HERE TODAY TO
SHARE WITH YOU MY CONCERNS.
NURSE AND A NEW GRADUATE. BUT
THE BEER AND IS LIMITING ACCESS
TO STUDENTS AND OPERATING
WITHOUT A CHECK AND BALANCE
FROM THE LEGISLATOR.
CALIFORNIA'S CARE FOR AN AGING
AND CULTURALLY DIVERSE
POPULATION AS A TRADING DEMAND
FOR NURSES ON ALL LEVELS LV
ENDS AT ENDS AND BE ESSENCE. AT
MY HOSPITALS SO OVER NURSES ARE
NEARING RETIREMENT AND WE ARE
ALL WORKING LONG HOURS UNDER
STRENUOUS PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL CIRCUIT CONSISTS
TRYING TO PROVIDE THE BEST CARE
WE CAN. BUT I AM VERY WORRIED
THAT WILL NOT ENOUGH NURSES IN
THE ATTENTION QUALITY CARE
ESPECIALLY I CAN BASE HOSPITALS
WHICH ARE CRITICAL TO THE
MEETING THE DIDN'T THE NEEDS OF
DISADVANTAGED PEOPLE FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE. CALIFORNIA'S
ISRAEL I FIFTY YEARS OF WAIT
LISTS AND LOTTERY DRAWS AT UP
TO THREE DIFFERENT SCHOOLS
TRYING TO GAIN ENTRY INTO A
PROGRAM. I WAS ABLE TO. FIND A
SCHOOL THAT ACCEPTED ME BUT I'M
NOT ALL. ALL BUT NOT ALWAYS
SPOKEN AS I AM MANY QUALIFIED
STUDENTS ARE TURNED WERE TURNED
AWAY LOOK TOWARDS ANOTHER
CAREER THERE WHERE THEY CAN
ACHIEVE WITHOUT. IN PART TIME
MINIMUM WAGE JOBS TO MAKE ENDS
MEET. IN GENERAL EDUCATION TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR CREDITS DON'T
EXPIRE BEFORE THEY'RE IN MADE
INTO A PROGRAM. IT IS TIME. DO
SUPPORT THIS AUDIT AND USE ITS
FINDINGS TO HELP YOU ENSURE
CALIFORNIA IS DOING ALL IT
CAN'T EDUCATE THE HEALTHCARE
WORKERS OF TOMORROW. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
STATE OUT OF HER PLACE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO KATIE
THIS ONE OF THE MR NURSING
FIRST PRIMARY OBJECTIVE IS
REALLY LOOKING THEIR PROCESS.
FOR APPROVING NINE REVOKING
NURSING PROGRAMS LOOKING TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
BOARD IS ACTUALLY COMPLYING
WITH LAWS AND REGULATIONS. AND
THEN A SUBSET OF THAT IT WAS
REALLY LOOKING AT SCHOOLS THAT
WANT TO EXPAND PROGRAMS. ACTORS
WE ARE AS YOU TO MAKE
TERMINATION BEST WEAPON OUT. OF
THAT EXPANSION OR TO DENY THE
REQUEST TO EXPAND AND SHE'S
ASKING UP SHORT AT THE REGISTER
SING IS A PLOT IT'S FACT.
CONSISTENTLY ACROSS YES
REQUEST. THE ENGINE SO THE
OBJECT REALLY LOOKING AT. WHAT
SHE'S ASKING US TO DO IS NOT
CERTAINLY NOT QUESTION ALE IN
THEIR DECISION MAKING BUT
REALLY GET A GET AN INVENTORY
OF THE TYPES OF COMPLAINTS THAT
HAVE. HELD AND WHAT THE
ESSENTIALLY OUT OF THOSE
PARTICULAR COMPLAINTS HAVE BEEN
OVER A THREE YEAR WINDOW THE
MOST RECENT THREE YEARS. IN
ADDITION SHE GERMAN MISTER
SALAS ARE ASKING US TO LOOK AT
ANY GUIDELINES OR PROTOCOLS
THAT THE BOARD REGISTERED
NURSES PROVIDES TO ITS STAFF
AND CERTAINLY TO BOARD MEMBER
WITH THREE THE CONFLICT OF IT.
IN DETERMINING WHAT THEY'RE NOT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS PROPERLY RICK.
WHEN THERE'S A DETERMINATION
ARE A PROGRAM THAT THEY MAY
HAVE HAD A RELATION. SO REALLY
LOOKING TO MAKE SURE THIS
PROPER GUIDANCE AND AN
EXECUTION OF A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST POLICIES AND
PROTOCOLS. ON A PARTICULAR AREA
THAT WAS MENTIONED IN THE
REQUEST LETTER THAT SHE HAS
ASKED US TO LOOK AT AS CLINICAL
DISPLACEMENT. OUR PROCESS AND
THIS IS WHERE SCHOOL MADE THIS.
STATE FOR ALL TYPES OF STUDENTS
IN ASKING US AGAIN LOOKING AT
CONCERTS AND SEE PROCESS
DECISION MAKING WITH RESPECT
TO. OUR SITUATIONS WHERE
CLINICAL DISPLACEMENT. OCCURS
ON THE LAST COUPLE OF
OBJECTIVES. IS SITE YOU HEARD.
ABOUT A NATION SO THE QUESTION
THAT IS RUBIO IS ASKING US TO
LOOK AT IS WHAT TO BE OUR ENDS
OVERSIGHT AND WATER FUNCTIONS
ARE THEY CONDUCTING OR
ACTIVITIES ARE THEY CONDUCTING
VERSUS WHAT CREDITING AGENCY
COM OR ASSOCIATION COMES IN IT
IS THERE IS B. R. AND DOING
THINGS THAT TYPICALLY BY AN
ACCREDITING OUR AGENCY IN A
NURSING SCHOOL SO WHAT TO SEE
IF THERE IS A DUPLICATE IF
THERE'S OVERLAP. SITE AND THEN
LAST AREAS. LOOKING OUT WORKING
WORKFORCE ANALYSIS WHAT. DOES
IRAN AT NO THEY WITH THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA AND GOT
SOME ANALYSIS SHE'S ASKING US
TO COMPARE THEIR- THESE TO
OTHER ANALYSES THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE AND WHAT IS THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING DO. WITH
RESPECT TO NOT ONLY LOOKING AT
THE ANALYSES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED TO THEM BY THEIR
CONCERTS SINCE. OTHER AND SEES
TO REALLY GATE. THE WORK FORCE
TO LOOK LIKE IN THE FUTURE AND
WHAT THE DEMAND WILL BE FOR A
NURSES IN CALIFORNIA. AND THE
BUDGET FOR THIS PARTICULAR
AUDIT TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED HOURS
THAT'S ABOUT A SIX MONTH
PROJECT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
RIGHT. THANK YOU. WITH THAT
WILL GO HEAD TO MOVE TO THE
AFFECTED AGENCIES
. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU IF YOU KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO SINK TO THE AUDIT
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT JUST LIKE
THE PREVIOUS I REQUEST THAT WE
HAD. PLEASE BEGIN BY SAYING
YOUR NAME. THANK YOU. THE
MORNING HI I'M DOCTOR JOE MORE
SEND EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
BOARD. BUT TO MY RIGHT PARK DR
SUSAN ANGLE NURSING EDUCATION
CONSULTANT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
THANK YOU. AND HIDE DOCTOR
DOLENZ BUT SOME AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO CONTRACTOR TO THE
BOARD AND AWARE OF THE NURSING
SHORTAGE DATA. THANK YOU.
CHRISTINE IS FOR DEPUTY CHIEF
OF THE LICENSING AND
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES WITH
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING.
OKAY THANK YOU. THE MORNING ON
WHICH HEARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AGAIN I AM DOCTOR
JOSEPH MORRIS ALSO REGISTERED
NURSE AND EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. THE BOARD
IS THE LARGEST HEALING ARTS FOR
IN THE UNITED STATES WITH OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND LICENSEES
AND APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR NURSING
SCHOOLS. THE BOARD'S MISSION TO
PROTECT AN ADVOCATE FOR THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY THE PUBLIC.
I'M HERE ALONG WITH THE STAFF
TO ADDRESSING YOUR CONCERNS.
RESPECTFULLY THE BOARD DOES NOT
FEEL THIS PROPOSE AUDIT IS
WARRANTED. THE BOARD IS
CONFIDENT IN ASSURING THE
COMMITTEE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ALREADY SUCCESSFULLY AVERTED
THE NURSING SHORTAGE. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT THE NUMBER OF
NURSES. THAT ARE LICENSE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA HAS DEALT FROM
200-500-0025 HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND. AND THE NUMBER OF
APPROVED SCHOOLS HAVE INCREASE
FROM ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN TO
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR.
THEREFORE FUNDAMENTAL REASON
FOR DISAGREEING REQUEST NUMBER
ONE THE CONTEXT OF PERCEPTION
OF THE STATEWIDE NURSING
SHORTAGE DOCTOR SPECS A
RENOWNED ECONOMIST IN LEE
RESEARCHER CONTRACTED BY THE
BOARD SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HAS PROVIDED NUMEROUS REPORTS
INDICATING THAT THE NURSING
FORCES ADEQUATELY POSITIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HOWEVER
SHE HAS IN HER RESEARCH THERE
ARE REGIONAL DIFFERENCES.
SECOND THERE ADEQUATE CHECKS
AND BALANCES TO THE- INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED TO THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS THE PUBLIC
RECORDS REQUEST ACT AND THE
OPEN MEETINGS. THIRD THIS AUDIT
COULD REQUIRE A REVIEW AND FOR
ALL OF THE ENTITIES SUCH AS THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW.
UCSF AND THE F. PPC.
ADDITIONALLY THIS ARCTIC COULD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
LITIGATION INVOLVING THE BOARD.
LAST WEEK TO ENSURE THAT THE
NEW PROGRAMS SCHOOL APPROVAL
AND EXPANSION PROCESS IS
EQUITABLE AND TRANSPARENT THE
NURSING EDUCATION SULTANS AND
THE BOARD USE THE REGULATORY
STANDARD OUTLINED IN SIXTEEN C.
C. R. FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO AND THEIR
RECOMMENDATION TO DISTANCE WERE
PROVEN SCHOOLS. THE BOARD
RECOGNIZED THE STAKEHOLDERS
CONFUSION BROWN OF OUR
AUTHORITY REGARDING ENROLLMENT.
AND BRING IT BRING TO BRING
CLARITY TO THIS ISSUE. EARLY
THE BOARD IS CURRENTLY
PROPAGATING REGULATIONS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DELAY IN
YOUR VOTE SO THAT WE CAN WORK
THIS OUT. HEY CLOSING. THE
BOARD I WANT TO THINK THE
LEGISLATORS FOR THEIR APPROVING
ABOUT SIXTY SEVEN POSITIONS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THESE
POSITIONS WILL HELP SUPPORT THE
BOARDS MISSION AND ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE TO UPDATE OUR
PROCESSES AND IDENTIFY
EFFICIENCIES TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC THANK YOU ARE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AT THE SIMON
WE ASK IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL
AFFECTED AGENCIES. HEY WE WILL
TURN IT BACK TO MEMBERS ON THE
DOT YES WE WILL BEGIN WITH
QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR ROBB.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. YOU
KNOW THIS IS A COMPLICATED
ISSUE AND IT'S ONE THAT I'VE
BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT FOR SOME
TIME AND- WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME IN THIS. IN THIS BUILDING.
AND I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
COVERS IS DEALING WITH.
DECISION SHORTAGES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE. CHARGES OF OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. I OF
COURSE IN PRIVILEGEDTO
REPRESENT A DISTRICT IN INLAND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND- I HAVE
COLLEAGUES THAT REPRESENT TO
ANOTHER DISTRICT IT'S TO THE
EAST TO MAIL IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY. THIS ABOUT WHETHER
THERE'S AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF
NURSES OR SHORTAGE OF NURSES I
GUESS IF YOU AVERAGE THE NURSE
PRODUCTION IN THE NURSES THAT
ARE PRACTICING UP AND DOWN THE
STATE AND- ADEQUATE. BUT I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT. HELLO VALLEY
WHO DO NOT FEEL IT'S A SURPRISE
ADEQUATE AND IN LOOKING AT THE
BOARD'S OWN REPORT THE HEADLINE
WAS INTERESTING TO ME TODAY ON
TWENTY ONE MEETING FUTURE NEEDS
FOR NURSES A CHALLENGE OF BOTH
NUMBERS AND SKILLS. AND YOUR
OWN REPORT YOU SAY THERE IS A
VERY THE ADEQUACY OF OUR AND
SUPPLY ACROSS REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE RECENT
ANALYSIS THE SANDWICH ONLY
PROJECTED SIGNIFICANT OUR
SHORTAGES OVER THE NEXT FIFTEEN
YEARS. SO THIS ISSUE ABOUT
RESTRICTING ENROLLMENT AT
NURSING SCHOOLS IS PROBLEMATIC
HE WITHOUT FURTHER ANALYSIS IN
AN EFFORT TO DO WHAT WE'RE
DOING ON THE PHYSICIAN AREA
WHICH IS TO. ATTEMPT TO
INCENTIVIZE AND. TING GRADUATE.
I MOVED TO IN PRACTICE. IS
WHERE THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
SHORTAGE NOW I'M NOT A HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER WE HAVE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS ON THE PANEL.
CERTAINLY DEFERRED TO THEM. FOR
THEIR EXPERTISE SO WE HAVE THIS
ISSUE ABOUT ADEQUATE SUPPLY OR
SHORTAGE THAT CERTAINLY NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED BUT SOUNDS LIKE
BOARD IN SOME PUBLICATION HAS.
RECOGNIZED AS SOME OF THOSE
SHORTAGES WE ALSO A SITUATION.
WELL AND NOW I'VE SAID ON
EDUCATION BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
SO I KNOW THE FUNDING WE HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE
INSUFFICIENT FUNDING TOWARD OUR
PUBLIC. NURSING PROGRAMS POSTED
THE CAL STATE AND IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. SYSTEM AND
THE ONES WE HAVE ARE IMPACTED
BEYOND BELIEF WITH WAITING
LISTS THAT PEOPLE GROW OLD CITY
AND- AWAITING SLOT ONE OF ITS
PRO. THEN FOR PUBLIC THIS IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S BEEN
A OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
IT SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN THE-
ACCREDITATION STANDARDS FOR OUR-
ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS WHERE IN
ORDER TO. ATTAIN A TOP. OF
ACCREDITING STANDARD MAGNET
STATUS THE HOSPITAL IS. SORT OF
FORCED TO EITHER HIGHER. BSN
BATCHES DEGREE NURSES ARE
NURSES THAT ARE IN TRAINING TO
GET THEIR BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
WHICH PROBABLY IMPACTS THE
DESIRE OF SOME OF THESE
HOSPITALS TO. SIGN UP WITH
COMMUTE ARE VERY EXCELLENT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS AND TAKE THEIR
STUDENTS IN TRAINING BECAUSE OF
COURSE THIS IS AN ADDED. BURDEN
ON THE HOSPITAL TRYING TO
PROVIDE MEDICAL CARE THAT.
PROVIDE BILLABLE SERVICES IN
HOSPITALS ICE BACK TO USE THIS
AS A MEANS TO REVIEW AND WATCH
NURSING STUDENT THE SERVER
WHICH ONES ARE GOING HIGHER AND
IF THE PREFERENCES. ARE BAD.
HIS DEGREE IS THERE. TO PUT.
THAT'S RETRAINING. MISSING
STUDENTS IN TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THEM. AND OF COURSE WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL OF MADE SEVERAL
ATTEMPTS IN THIS HOUSE OVER THE
LAST FIVE OR SIX OR SEVEN YEARS
TO. GRANT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE ASSORTED WORK
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN THERE CAN
PROGRAMS IN THOSE EFFORTS HAVE
HAVE BEEN DEFEATED EACH EACH
AND EVERY TIME. THAT THEY'VE
BEEN PUT FORWARD SO. OF OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE IMPACTED
DOES IT DEMAND FOR BACHELORS
DEGREE NURSES WE HAVE AN
EXPANDED THE NUMBER OF
INSTITUTIONS THAT AWARD BATCHES
DEGREES. OUR COMMUNITY ARE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
NURSING PROGRAM PIPELINE FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. TO THE C.
ISSUES IS CLOGGED. TO SAY THE
LEAST WE BEGUN SOME EFFORTS AND
PILOT PROGRAMS TO SORT OF OPEN
UP THAT PIPELINE TO. PERMIT OF
MORE FLOWS THROUGH FROM OUR-
EIGHTY IN TO BE AS AN PROGRAM
BUT- THAT'S YET TO SPEAK WE GET
TO SEE WHETHER THOSE EFFORTS
ARE GONNA. EXCEPT FOR. SO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED BY EITHER AN AUDIT OR
AN OVERSIGHT HEARING IN
PROBABLY THE OUGHT IT'S THE
BEST WAY TO DO IT. IS A REALLY
A CLINICAL SLOT. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA OR IS THE- SLOT
PROBLEM ONE WHERE THE HOSPITALS
WHERE WE DO THE CORE MOST OF
THE CLINICAL WORK I ASSUME ARE
PREFERRING BATCHES DEGREES
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
ACCREDITING AGENCIES WANT THEM
TO OR THE OR THEIR OTHER
ALTERNATIVES FOR CLINICAL SLOT
PLACEMENTS. FOR OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE NURSING PER. COULD DO
THE SAME THING PROVIDE THE SAME
TRIP AND PROVIDE THE SAME HIGH
QUALITY NURSES THAT WE HAVE TO
TAKE COMING OUT OF THOSE
PROGRAMS. DOES THE BOARD
AUTHORITY. I DISAGREE WITH WITH
THE DIRECTOR AS HE KNOWS DOES
THE BOARD HAVE AUTHORITY WITHIN
THE EXISTING STATUTES AND
REGULATIONS TO ADJUST
ENROLLMENT UP OR DOWN. BECAUSE
AS- THE PROPONENT OF THIS
REQUEST NOTED WE DON'T DO THAT
IN ANY OTHER PROFESSION. AND I
READ THE REGULAR WHEN I READ
THE STATUTE IN PARTICULAR THE
REGULATION THAT YOU CITE. AND
I'M NOAH THIRTY FOR THE BOARD
TO MAKE ANY ADJUSTMENT UP OR
DOWN AND ENROLLMENT RATHER YOUR
THIRTY IS TO APPROVE OR
DISAPPROVE PROGRAMS AND IF YOU
WANT THE AUTHORITY IN MY VIEW
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS. AND THE AND THE
STANDARDS HAVE TO TIED TO
FACILITIES FACULTY TO STUDENT
RATIO BRICK AND MORTAR
FACILITIES AND THE LIKE SO. I
WAS TAUGHT LAW SCHOOL TO ASK A
QUESTION THERE IS NO QUESTION
THERE I WANTED TO MAKE MY
POSITION HOWEVER CLEAR. IN MY-
EXPRESSION OF SUPPORT FOR THE
AUDIT NO I DO. ONE OF THE
DISADVANTAGES OF BEING ON THIS
COMMITTEE I AM HEARING OTHER
REQUESTS AS WE REALLY DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE DRAFTING OF THE
QUESTIONS AS I'VE INDICATED TO
THE- AND I'VE I THINK THAT ARE
SOME QUESTIONS SUCH AS THE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST QUESTION
IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
QUESTION THAT ARE NOT REALLY
RELEVANT TO MY CONCERNS. AND I
WOULD PREFER THAT THOUGH. BUT
IT BUT I DO THINK THAT THE OVER.
ISSUES OF CLINICAL SLOT
AVAILABILITY. HOW WE RESTRICT
ENROLLMENT AND BY THE WAY THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS STEPPED UP. IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL. WHEN
SUFFICIENT. AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE AND HOW WE
RESTRICT AND ROMAN TO THAT THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS OF ONE WE CAN'T
GRADUATE ENOUGH IN OUR PUBLIC
PROGRAM. AT A TIME WHEN WE HAVE
SHORTAGES AROUND THE STATE. SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS. THE
AUDIT I WOULD ASK AND I'M SURE
I HAVE SOME COLLEAGUES THAT ARE
GONNA BE ASKING THESE QUESTIONS
THE AUTHOR TO TAKE A LOOK AT
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS AND
BETTER THAN THE OTHER REQUEST.
BUT I LOOK FORWARD THE AUDIT
REPORT TO MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR STATEMENT AND YEAH
JUST TO CLARIFY IT IS IN THE
LAST THE PREVIOUS I REQUEST TO
KNOW WE'RE- COMMITTED BY THE
JOINT RULES. AS AMENDING THE.
TELLING WATER. WITH THAT WE DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF MEMBERS WITH.
WE WILL MOVE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON CENTER MORE LIKE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT. THANK
CHAIR. I WANT TO ASSOCIATE MY
MIKE COMMENTS WITH THE SENATE
ROTH WE SHOULD THE COMMENTS
THAT HE MADE I ALSO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE- AUTHOR OF
THIS. AND I WANT US TO BE
THINKING A LITTLE ABOUT THE
BUREAUCRACY IN A LITTLE LESS
ABOUT WHETHER THERE'S A
SHORTAGE OF WHETHER THERE IS A
SHORTAGE OBVIOUSLY THERE IS
AMPLE EVIDENCE THAT THEIR
SHORTAGES IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
INTO THE NIGHT. IS BIG RECALL
WITH THOSE OF US WHO REPRESENT
THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. SUGGEST
THAT WE NEED TO BE THINKING.
ABOUT STUDENTS. WHO HAVE A
PASSION. WHO OFTENTIMES GO INTO
NURSING AS A CALLING. AND FOR
THE B. R. N. TO ESSENTIALLY BE
THE GATEKEEPER TO THEIR
OPPORTUNITY A GATEKEEPER TO
THEIR DREAMS ARE I THINK YEAH.
RAISES THE REAL QUESTION WE'RE
NOT BE IRAN IS ACTUALLY.
PERFORMING SARAH STATUTORY
DUTIES OR GETTING INTO AREAS IT
HAS NO BUSINESS GETTING INTO.
BUT LET'S STIPULATE FOR THAT
THERE MAY OR MAY NOT BE A
SHORTAGE. THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
SEEKING AN EDUCATION. AND THEY
ARE SEEKING A PASSION THEY ARE
SEEKING TO BE. A LICENSED AND
ABLE TO DO THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN TRAINED
FOR. AND THAT THEY WANT TO DO.
DOES IT MATTER WHETHER OR NOT
THERE IS A SHORTAGE HERE. I
DON'T THINK SO. BECAUSE THEY
CAN FIND. REWARDING NURSING
SERVICE. IN PLACES OTHER THAN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
QUITE FRANKLY THAT TO ME I
ESTáN ARRAKIS ADJUSTED. I
THINK THERE'S A HUGE OVER REACH
A HUGE OVER STEP. IN WHAT BE
ARE AND- IS IT IS ATTEMPTING TO
DO HERE I AGREE WITH MY BREAD
BREAD DISPATCHERS I FIND NO.
GRANT OF THE KIND OF AUTHORITY
THAT YOU'RE ATTEMPTING TO
EXERCISE HERE IT ESSENTIALLY
SHUTTING DOWN SAYING NO I THINK
YOUR RESPONSIBILITY IS. WITH
RESPECT TO HEALTH AND SAFETY IN
THESE KIND AND THE EXPERTISE
AND TRAINING ALL OF THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS. TO SAY YES. TO THOSE
WHO ARE QUALIFIED THOSE WHO ARE
READY TO GO TO WORK IN THOSE
WHO ARE ARE ARE PASSING THEIR
TESTS AND DOING EVERYTHING
WE'VE EXPECTED THEM TO DO BUT
INSTEAD YOU'RE SAYING NO. OR
WAIT OR MAYBE. REPRESENTING
GENDER CALIFORNIA HERE AND ALSO
MAYOR FOR EIGHT YEARS FRESNO I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THIS IS ONE
OF THE NUMBER ONE ISSUES OF
CONCERN THAT CONSTITUENTS IN MY
AREA TALK TO ME ABOUT WE
REGULARLY INTEREST HE. WITH B.
R. AT QUITE FRANK. ON BEHALF OF
ST STE GRADUATES WHO HAVE.
EMPLOYMENT IN OUR HOSPITALS.
AND CANNOT BE APPROVED IN A
TIMELY WAY ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE
CROSSED ALL THE TEASE DOT ALL
THE I'S THEY HAVE IN FACT DONE
ALL OF THE THINGS WE EXPECT
THEM TO DO. BUT THE CLOCK RUNS
OUT. WE HAD A. A SERIES OF
CONSTITUENT THE CONCERNS THAT
WE HAD WOULD ADDRESS WITH
CONSTITUENTS ARE PROCESS WITH
RESPECT TO AT LEAST FIVE NURSES
WHO HAD CONDITIONAL JOB OFFERS
FROM MILD ONE OF OUR- WONDERFUL
HOSPITALS. AND THEY WERE IN THE
CLOCK WAS RUNNING OUT AND THEY
COULDN'T GET THROUGH AND YOU
KNOW WHAT WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
I BEEN APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU WERE WILLING. TO LISTEN TO
OUR- ONCE AND THERE WERE SOME.
DISCRETION USED AT LEAST NURSES
ARE ARE EMPLOYED. BUT THAT'S
BACKWARDS TO THE WAY THEY
SHOULD BE. THE RED CARPET ARE
ROLLING OUT TO THE STUDENTS. AT
YOUR PLACE. WE'VE GOT TO
INTERVENE AND FUNDAMENTAL
THINGS. LIKE LIKE LIKE ACTUAL
DUE PROCESS. IS REALLY
DISCOURAGING SO I REALLY FEEL
LIKE IT IN I'M GOING TO GO TO
APPROVE THIS ALOT I APPRECIATE.
THE WHAT IS BEEN SAID HERE WITH
WITH RESPECT TO THE- BUT OVER
REACH OF THE. THEY ARE IN BUT I
THINK. IT'S COMPLICATED I
UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS BUT LET'S
NOT LET COMPLICATION GET IN THE
WAY OF THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION
HERE. IN A FREE SOCIETY IN A
FREE ECONOMY IN A FREE STATE.
TO THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO PROCEED FORWARD AND
GET THEIR LICENSES IN THIS
STATE SO THAT THEY CAN REALIZE
THEIR DREAM. AND UNFORTUNATELY
I THINK WE ARE IN IS STANDING
IN THEIR WAY AND I HOPE THIS
AUDIT WILL CLEAR THE WAY AND
HELP. I THINK THE STEW. COULD
NOT ASK FOR WHAT THEY'RE DOING
FIND A SLOT AND BE ABLE TO GET
ON WITH THEIR PASSION AND GET
ON WITH THEIR CALLING. RIGHT.
YOUR WITHOUT WILL JUST CENTER
MORE LOCKED INTO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD THEN TO ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BERNHARDT. DOCTOR MORRIS
YES SIR I HAVE A QUESTION.
FIRST WELCOME. YOU MAKE YOUR
OPENING REMARKS AND ONE OF THE
SITE COMMENTS WAS THAT YOU WERE
IN LITIGATION BUT YOU DID NOT
ELABORATE SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
COULD YOU. SO. RESPECT THERE WE
AGAIN WE ARE IN LITIGATION WITH
ONE OF THE SCHOOLS AND SOUL.
CHALLENGES AGAIN THE VOICE
AUTHORITY SO. PORTION I CAN'T
GO INTO DETAIL. WITH THAT IF
WITH THAT LITIGATION IS SO IT'S
SCHOOL VERSES BE ARE IN AND
THAT'S IT. IN A NUTSHELL. YES
SO THEN WHY DID YOU MENTION IT.
BECAUSE IT AGAIN GOING INTO
DETAILS OF THE LITIGATION AND
IT COULD POSSIBLY INFLUENCE THE
POTENTIAL EMPLOYEES THE
AUDITOR'S. IT'S NOT REPORT.
WHAT COMES OUT OF THE
LITIGATION. OKAY I'M NOT A
LAWYER I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT YOU MENTION IT IT
WAS ONE OF YOUR ARGUMENTS AND
YES. YOU'RE NOT HELPING ME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
BUT WITHOUT WILL MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT. YES THANK
YOU. JUST I JUST HAVE SOME
CA A COUPLE QUESTIONS YOU
KNOW TYPICALLY WHEN WE DO THESE
AUDIT REQUESTS WE ASK THE
AGENCY. FORMALLY YOU KNOW DâN
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE BASS
OR DID YOU ACTUALLY READ MAKE A
LETTER OF REQUEST THE AGENCY TO
ANSWERS ANY QUESTION YOU'RE
ASKING. NOT BETTER WE'VE BEEN
ENCOMPASSES IS BECAUSE OF THE
ALL THAT I HAD ALREADY
ORIGINALLY. DURING THE YEAR SO
NO THERE IS NOT A FORMAL
LETTER. OKAY JUST WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IS TYPICALLY
TE. WAY WE DO THINGS SO DID
YOU GET ANY FEEDBACK. I KNOW
WHAT I GOT WAS AND THAT'S HOW
WE DO IT. CITING THE AND THEN
THERE ARE THIRTY TO DO SO. I
WOULD AGREE WITH SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WHILE THERE MAY
NOT BE A GROSS ENOUGH AMOUNT OF
A SHORTAGE OF NUMBERS. THERE
CERTAINLY IS OUR CHALLENGES AND
CERTAIN REGIONAL AREAS CENTRAL
VALLEY IS OF SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN THE INLAND EMPIRE IS A
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN. THE NORTH
COAST IS OF SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
AND IT IS DIFFICULT TO GET
PEOPLE PEOPLE BEAR SO I GUESS
PART OF I AM CONFLICTED HERE
QUITE FRANKLY I HAVE. TWO OF MY
NURSING PRO. TO OUR OFFICE THE
ITEM. THAT THAT REBELS ME. BUT
ALSO. YOUR STAND THAT THERE MAY
BE VALUABLE INFORMATION COMES
FROM THIS AUDIT BUT- WE HAVE
ANOTHER PROCESS CALLED SUNSET
REVIEW. AND THAT'S COMING SOON.
AND BACK GIVE OUR- FOLKS IN THE
CAPITAL AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY TAKE A DEEP DIVE INTO
SOME THINGS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE. YOU MIGHT HAVE
INFORMATION COME OUT AND AUDIT.
BUT THE REALITY IS THE SUNSET
REVIEW HAS ACTUALLY THE
AUTHORITY IN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE CHANGE. OR TO MOVE THINGS
FORWARD SO. I KIND OF FEEL A
BIT OF WRITTEN IN C. YOU MIGHT
THE JUMP START BY GETTING SOME
INFORMATION BUT THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS IS GOING TO PLAY
OUT. I'M AND THAT WILL BEGIN
THE PREPARATION FOR THAT WILL
BEGIN I BELIEVE NEXT YEAR. SO
AM I AM CONFLICTED AND OUT BY
THAT I AM OBVIOUSLY HAD BEEN A
HUGE PROPOSED FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BUT ALSO WONDER TOO
IT'S PART OF THIS ISSUE AND I
DON'T KNOW. I'M NOT AN EXPERT
ON THE BOARD'S AUTHORITY ON
THIS. BUT YOU WONDER YOU KNOW.
WHEN SHE IS. ARE THERE ARE
THERE CLINICAL SO THAT'S TO PUT.
SO FOR EXAMPLE. A RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
TENNIS RIGHT NOW. FOR FAMILY
PRACTICE RESIDENCIES AND
PRIMARY CARE. AND THERE REALLY
AREN'T A LOT OF SLOTS FOR THOSE
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS. PART
BECAUSE THEY ARE HUGELY
EXPENSIVE. THERE HE IS
EXPENSIVE TO RUN AND TO
MAINTAIN. SO HOSPITALS IN AND
PLACES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
PLATE IT PARTICIPATE IN THE
EDUCATION NURSES. I JUST DON'T
KNOW IF WE ARE MAXED OUT ON
THAT OR IF THERE IS IF THERE IS
AN ISSUE WITH THAT AND THAT IS
THAT WHY THE BOARD BUT BOARD IS
ENTERTAINING. BUT I DO BELIEVE
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WOULD
ALSO COME OUT AND SET TO
REVIEW. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT. BECAUSE YOU ARE CORRECT
BUT THE I DID WOULD IDENTIFY
THAT IT. AYE AND SUB ONE A WITH
YOU WE'VE ALWAYS PUSHED FOR
ADDITIONAL MONIES SPECIFIC IN
THE AND THEN OUR CASE FOR
DOCTORS ON TO BE PLAYED AND I
THINK THAT THE AUDITOR CAM. A
GROUP. OF BETTER INTEREST. OF
ISN'T AN. BOB WHAT I. NUMBER OF
THE SUB COMMITTEE AND- SERVICES
TO PUSH FOR ADDITIONAL MONIES
AND- MEMBER OF THE- PUSH FOR
ADDITIONAL MONIES. TO SUPPORT
SOME OF THESE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS. AND FRANKLY WORK
WITH THE HOSPITALS TO SEE IF WE
CAN PROVIDE. MORE MORE SPOTS.
AND I THINK THE AUDIT. WOULD
IDENTIFY THAT I. HAVE BEEN
WORKING NOW WITH THE AUDITOR
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS
SITTING ON THIS COMMITTEE AND
SHE'S VERY. GOOD AT NOT JUST
FINDING THE AMER INFORMATION
BUT ALSO GIVING RECOMMENDATIONS
AS TO WHAT. IS TO BE. AND I
FOUND. THAT OUR- DEPARTMENTS
NEED. EXT HELP AS- GET IT
OBVIOUS THEIR VIEW BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO ON A DAILY
BASIS THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
TO HAVE THE INDEPENDENT AUDITOR
TO LOOK AT IT WITH A FRESH VIEW
AND GIVE RECOMMENDATIONS NOT
ONLY TO THE DEPARTMENT BUT ALSO
TO US AS LEGISLATORS PROVIDE.
EASE MAYBE DIGITAL SUPPORT SIDE
I. WON WERE. BEEN TEACHING FOR
ADDITIONAL SLOTS FOR. AND
PROVIDED THAT MONEY THAT THOSE
DOCTORS ARE BEINGS OR THE
POTENTIAL DOCTORS ARE BEING.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THE CLINICAL STUDY THAT WOULD
GIVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY IN SOME.
TO ASK FOR ADDITIONAL MONIES
FOR ADDITIONAL SLOTS FOR YOU
KNOW IF THERE IS A NEED AND THE
US CENTRAL VALLEY I'M FROM LA
COUNTY AND I LOOKED AT THE
PRESENT LA COUNTY. WE HAVE NO
SHORTAGE AS A MATTER OF FACT WE
HAVE AN OVERSUPPLY OVERSUPPLY
OF FIFTEEN THOUSAND FIVE I
REPRESENT MY. CALIFORNIA THE
WHOLE AND SEE THAT IN THE SAID
ABOUT. I HAVE SOME GOAL LET ME
THOUSAND NURSES IN THE VALLEY
FOUR THOUSAND NURSES THERE'S
SEVERAL AREAS THAT HAVEN'T I
NEED AND- FOR ME IT'S ABOUT THE
WHOLE STATE NOT JUST
NECESSARILY MIGHT REGION AGAIN
I LOVE THAT I'M IN LA COUNTY
AND WE DON'T HAVE THIS ISSUE
BUT I HAVE BEEN VISITING THE
CENTRAL VALLEY I VISITED WITH
SOME FARMERS YESTERDAY. THOSE
FARMERS DON'T THE CROP WORKERS
DON'T HAVE ACCESS FOR VARIOUS
BRANDS AND ONE OF THE REASONS
IS THAT THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
ACCESS AND PART OF THAT ACTS AS
A- OF THE- BACK OF. THE END AND
YOU POINT OUT REALLY GOOD
THINGS AND I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH ANY OF THAT BUT HOW DO YOU
GET PEOPLE. TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES. HOW DO YOU GET
WELL TRAINED IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES BIG. AND ACT AS A
SHIP FROM UP OUR WAY. PROGRAM
AS A TEACHER AND WORKED FOR
FIVE YEARS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY PART OF MY FINANCIAL.
THAT WAS WAS RELIEVED WITH THAT
UPPER GRAND SO THAT WOULD GIVE
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO PERHAPS DO
A GRANT LIKE THAT FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES IF THEY MOVED INTO
THIS COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDE
THE ACCESS FOR THEM IS OUT OF
SCOPE OF THE AUDIT BUT IT IS
OUT OF SCHOOL BUT THE ADDED BUT
AGAIN WITH THE I DID WE WOULD
FIND OUT SPECIFICALLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING. THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE TO PUSH FOR
EXAMPLE TO BOB PROVIDED IN A
MONIES I SEE IT AS AN UP
OVERVIEW OF EVERYTHING HOW ARE
WE GOING TO PROVIDE NURSES FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES AND THE ODD
IT WOULD AT LEAST GIVE US THE
BASED OUT OF WHAT THE PROBLEMS
ARE AND IF THERE'S NO PROBLEMS
THEN THEN. I WOULD BE THE FIRST
ONE TO SEND OUT OF A PRESS
RELEASE TO. AND B. R. N. FOR
THEIR WORK BUT IF THERE'S
ISSUES THAT COME UP THAT THE
AUDITOR CAN BE. TOO THEN I
WOULD BE OPEN TO THAT SO THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE ACCESS AGAIN.
NOT JUST THE TALLY COUNTY I'M
FROM LA COUNTY I'M GOOD I
NEIGHBORS IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
NOT GOOD. AND SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ACCESS FOR
ALL. AND AGAIN I MET WITH THE-
FARMWORKERS YES THEY AND THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY ACCESS. NOW
THAT'S A WHOLE YOU'RE RIGHT IT
IS OUTSIDE OF THE SCOPE OF THE
AUDIT. BUT I DID. WAS CREATE
EITHER LEGISLATION. GRAHAM'S
THAT WOULD INCENTIVIZE THESE
THESE FOLKS MAYBE FROM ALLEY.
THE CENTER THAT I THINK WE MOVE
TOWARDS THAT I THINK WE ALL.
WANT ADDITIONAL ACCESS IS
TRYING TO PROVE THAT BELIEVE
MR. THING ABOUT. THE EFFORT
COAST WITH. ONE IN. CONTROL.
WELL REALLY DISCUSSING AND
WHETHER THE SCOPE. IT WILL
HELP. PRESS OF THAT WHETHER
FUTURE POLICY CONCERNS AND SUB
ONE ARE OF POLICY COMMITTEE OR
FUTURE LEGISLATION. RIGHT WITH
THAT I DON'T KNOW. QUESTION
MISTER WOOD OR JUST SAY THAT
YOU KNOW I PROBABLY WON'T BE
SUPPORTING THE ADDED TODAY
BECAUSE I BELIEVE WE HAVE
ANOTHER PROCESS IS CALLED
SUNSET REVIEW. AND WHICH WOULD
BE UP I'M A VERY BROAD. LENGTHY
PROCESS THAT WOULD GIVE THE
EVERYBODY OPPORTUNITY GET A LOT
OF THE ANSWERS YOU'RE ASKING
FOR US I'M NOT SAYING THAT
THERE'S NOT A NEED FOR MORE
INFORMATION. BY THE SAME I
THINK WE. ARE WE HAVE A PROCESS
THAT THAT WE CAN COMPLETE YOUR-
SIDE. THANKS BIRD. YOU KNOW I'M
COMING OF THIS WITH A PROBABLY
A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ON THE FIRST DAY I
WAS. INTO THE ASSEMBLY. I HAD A
FOR PROFIT NURSING COLLEGE AND
MY DISTRICT CLOSE. AND SO
LEARNED CASE WORK UP RIGHT OFF
THE BAT BEFORE I EVEN HAVE.
USED TO MY DISTRICT OFFICE. AND
WE HAD CONSTITUENTS THAT DIDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
TRANSCRIPTS. THAT COULDN'T MOVE
THAT YOU KNOW THAT WOULD CARRY
THE STUDENT LOAN THEY DIDN'T
KNOW HOW TO DISCHARGED ALONE.
SO WHEN I LOOKED AT THIS AUDIT
WHAT I LOOK THAT FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT ON A QUAN.
QUESTION HOW. ARE THEY.
OFFICIALLY CLOSED. NOW PLAYING
THE SLOT ALL THIS STUFF.
COMPLETELY LACKING FOR ME IS
THE QUALITY OF THE PROGRAMS.
RIGHT SO THAT'S WHAT WE KNOW.
AT AND THERE MIGHT NOT BE AN
OPTION TO CHANGE THE SCOPE IN
WHICH CASE I'M UNFORTUNATELY
CAN'T. SUPPORT THE ON IT TODAY.
BUT FOR ME WE SHOULD BE REALLY
LOOKING AT. YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS. ARE THE
COMPLAINTS COMING FROM FOR
PROFIT. FIVE IT OF COTTON
COLLEGES ARE THEY COMING FROM
NONPROFIT PROTOCOL IS ARE THEY
COMING FROM OUR PUBLIC COLLEGES
WHERE THE COMPLAINTS COMING
FROM. YOU KNOW WHAT WE LOOK AT
THE NUMBER OF SLOTS AND WE LOOK
AT THE CREDIT A YOU KNOW THE
HOW HOW THE B. R. AND-
EVALUATES PROGRAMS. HOWEVER
THEY EVALUATING QUALITY THE
COST TO THE PROGRAM YOU KNOW
HOW MUCH THAT OUR FOLKS REALLY
GONNA LEAVE WITH SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS. IS WHAT THEIR CONTROL
OF LIFELONG EARNING IS. SO I
THINK. IF WE'RE GONNA AUDIT.
ABOARD WE SHOULD DO IT
COMPREHENSIVELY I THINK SENATOR
ROTH IS BROUGHT UP SOME HIS
CONCERNS. AND I HAVE THE
CONCERNED ABOUT QUALITY OF
WHICH I DON'T FULLER
ADEQUATELY. ON INCLUDED HERE
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT. THE. WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT SORRY I'M OVER
FORTY SO I HAVE TO TAKE OFF MY
GLASSES WE TALK ABOUT. SOME OF
THE SLOTS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. I WONDER ABOUT THE
PROVISION OF THE SLOTS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT IS
MENTIONED AND WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN AND I HAD HEARD AND THOUGH
I DON'T HAVE THE IDEA VERIFY
THIS. SOME PEOPLE WITH SOME
ORGANIZATIONS CAN GIVE
DONATIONS TO GET MORE ACCESS TO
THE SPOTS HOW'S THAT AFFECTING
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM. SO I THINK
IF WE'RE GONNA YOU KNOW I
BASICALLY THINK YOU KNOW WE
SHOULD ON EVERYBODY THE STATE
THAT'S LIKE MY GENERAL RULE.
BUT IT'S GOING TO AUDIT THEM WE
SHOULD COMPREHENSIVELY AND
INCLUDES QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR
ROTH SOME OF THE MONTH. THAT I
HAVE A QUALITY OF PROGRAMS.
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE A PATH
TO A JOB. AND IF THAT'S BEST
DONE IN A COMPREHENSIVE. REVIEW
FORMAT Vì THE SON OF VIA THE
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS. YOU KNOW
I'LL BE THE FIRST TO HELP. YOU
KNOW MAKE SURE THAT SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS IS ADEQUATE
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE WE DO NEED
TO HAVE MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
PLACE IN OUR STATE. HAS TRAIN
NURSES THAT HAVE THE POTENTIAL
FOR JOBS THAT ARE REALLY.
ADDING TO THE HEALTH AND OF OUR
COMMUNITIES SO I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN THE SENSE THAT. YOU
BROUGHT THIS TO A CRITICAL
MOMENT WE'RE ALL WATCHING IT
BUT I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
SCOPE HERE THAN. WHAT'S
ACTUALLY BEEN BEEN DISK. THANK
YOU IT ALMOST TENER MINING. IN
MY DISTRICT HAVE HAD A NUMBER
OF COMPLAINTS FROM PEOPLE BEEN
HELD UP IN THE LICENSING
PROCESS SOME FROM OUT OF STATE
WHO COME INTO CALIFORNIA OTHERS
WHO GRADUATED FROM OUR
INSTITUTIONS. AND OTHERS IN ON
IT AND TWENTY SIXTEEN I BELIEVE
ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND
THAT THERE HAS BEEN IMPROVEMENT
OF BACKLOG IN IN FORWARD
PROGRESS AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY THINK THE
BOARD FOR. THAT I DO SHARE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS. RAISED BY DR
WOODS IN OTHERS. ABOUT THE
SCOPE OF THIS ON IT IN THE
TIMING. I THINK IT THE CORN IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAVE TOUCHED ON.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
SOME CONFLICT BETWEEN PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS OR PRIVATE
PROGRAMS SOME OF THE CONCERN
WE'VE SEEN WITH SOME PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS I KNOW SOME DO AN
AMAZING JOB AND OTHERS MAYBE.
NOT IS GREAT QUALITY BUT
SHOULDERING SOME STUDENTS WITH
DEBT. ENDS RUNNING BUSINESSES
AND SERVE FOR ME QUALITY IS THE
NUMBER ONE CONCERN OF WHETHER
IT'S PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
INSTITUTION I THINK THE BOARD
HAS A ROLE TO PLAY. IN A- THEIR
THE GATE KEEPER FOR QUALITY.
I'VE ALSO RECEIVED OPPOSITION
TO THIS AUDIT FROM AT LEAST
THREE COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR
INSTITUTIONS IN MY DISTRICT
NURSE PROGRAM. ORGANIZED LABOR
ON THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
IS PROVIDED ME WITH A LIST OF
ALTERNATIVE QUESTIONS OR
SUPPLEMENTAL QUESTIONS AND I
KNOW WE DON'T USE THIS HEARING
TO EXPAND THE SCOPE OF THE
AUDIT. BUT WHAT I WOULD ASK
THROUGH THE CHAIR IS IF WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE FOR THE AUTHOR.
I'M IN THE AUDITOR TO LOOK AT
THESE QUESTIONS AND SEE IF THEY
ARE WITHIN THE SCOPE OF WHAT
YOU HAVE ARTICULATED ENDS IN
POTENTIALLY INCORPORATE THE
SPIRIT OF THESE THAT ARE WITH
THE IN THE SCOPE OF THE CURRENT
AUDIT SHOULD RECEIVE THE VOTES
TODAY. ON IN AGAIN. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COMMENTS ARE NOT
THAT'S KIND OF THE SPIRIT
THOUGH OF MINE QUESTION WOULD
BE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING IF THAT
WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
THE AUDITOR. ALREADY PROPOSED.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE
ABSOLUTELY ORANGE. CNA AND
WHOEVER HAS A PERSPECTIVE ON
THE ON THIS PARTICULARWATER
REQUEST IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS
THAT CNN PROVIDED TO YOU SEE AN
EXCUSE ME INVITED TO YOU SEE AN
AD PROVIDED YOU. THAT WE
BELIEVE WOULD FIT IN THE SCOPE
OF A AND WOOD ESSENTIALLY
ASSIST US IN CONDUCTING THE
ANALYSIS WERE ABSOLUTELY. THING
TO DO THAT THERE MAY BE SOME
QUESTIONS THAT ARE OUTSIDE THE
SCOPE WE WOULDN'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY. IF THE COMMITTEE
APPROVES THE REQUEST TO ADD
THOSE NOW WE DO HAVE A WE
ALWAYS INCLUDE AN ADDITIONAL
OBJECTIVE WHERE WE WOULD ASSESS
ISSUES THAT ARE SIGNIFICANT TO
THE AUDIT SO WE MAY BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION. BUT
AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO GO BEYOND.
AUTHORITY OF THIS MOVING THE
AUDIT SO I WOULD WANT SURE
THERE'S AT LEAST A NEXUS RAY
YOU WHAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO
IS ASKING US TO DO. AND I HATE
THAT IN. FULLY UNDERSTAND THAT
THE GUIDELINES IN IN GUARD
RAILS BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE
THERE'S AN OPEN MIND TO LOOKING
AT THESE MEN AND I'M SEEING AND
NOT FROM THE AUTHORS WELL. SO
HAVING SAID ALL THAT I DON'T
KNOW THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE REQUEST TODAY BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE OPENNESS TO TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION CONCERNS AS
APPROPRIATE WITHIN THE SCOPE.
OF THE PROPOSED ON IT. SO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK CENTER
MINING AND LOADS US QUATRE HAVE
YOU HAD A CHANCE TO SEE THESE
IF NOT WE'LL GET NOW. MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU WITHOUT OF TO.
LISTEN TO YOUR GONZALEZ. I WANT
TO THANK A YOU CAN OF COURSE
ASSEMBLYMAN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
REVIEW. OF FOR BRING THIS ITEM
FORWARD. EARLIER TODAY I. VOTED
AGAINST IN ITEM THAT YOU
INVOLVED IN AUDIX I DIDN'T
THINK THERE WAS. AN OF
CONTROVERSY OR OR A SUSPICION
OF CONTROVERSY THAT WOULD ALLOW
FOR A RIGHT ISSUE TO BE LOOKED
INTO. THIS HOWEVER IS. PROBABLY
RIGHT IN FACT EVEN OVER RIGHT
ARE REPRESENTING THE CENTRAL
VALLEY I THINK EVERYONE STANDS
BASED THE COMMENTS YOU FOR. THE
DIRE SHORTAGE THAT WE HAVE. THE
PROSPECTS OF TALENT LEAVING THE
DIFFICULTY OF ATTRACTING
CULTIVATING WE'VE MADE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS WITH UCSF WITH
SOME OF THE OTHER NURSING
PROGRAMS AND IN MEDICAL
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
HAVE IN THE VALLEY. BUT WE'RE
NOT EVEN CLOSE TO ACTUALLY
MAKING THE STRONG A STAND IN.
FOR THE NEEDS THAT WE HAVE IN
THE FUTURE. I LOOK UPON THIS AS
NOT TOO DISSIMILAR TO SOME OF
THE DEBATES THAT WE HAD WITH
THE BAR ASSOCIATION. I WILL
MAKE CERTAIN THAT WE DON'T EVER
LET TORY ALYSSUM GET IN THE WAY
OF PROGRESS. IF WE'RE IN THE
INDUSTRY OF PROVIDING LEGAL
EDUCATION OR FOR IN THE
INDUSTRY PROVIDING MEDICAL
EDUCATION. THE ULTIMATE MISSION
IS TO PROVIDE SERVICE AND
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
EVERYONE. WE ARE SUFFERING IN
OUR AREA AND IF THERE'S A WAY
OF IN IN IMPROVING THE AMOUNT
OF SKILLED WORKERS SKILLED
STAFF. I'M IN THERE IS THAT
DIRECT NEXUS THAT WE'VE SEEN
BASS THE REPORTS I TOOK A LOOK
AT BEFORE. I THINK WE SHOULD
EMBRACE IT AND I AND I COMMEND
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR SAYING
IF THIS AUDIT DOES NOT LEAD TO.
A STRONG POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
NECESSARY WORKERS. AND CAL.
THEN SHE'LL BE WRITING YOU. A
LETTER COMMENDING YOU FOR THE
WORK THAT IT THAT YOU'VE BEEN
DOING. BUT LET'S NOT EVER LET
IT. HELP ME DONE THINGS IN THE
PAST KEEP US FROM IMPROVING AND
WE SEEM TO HAVE CHANGES WITH
THE BAR ASSOCIATION. HELPING SO
I THINK THAT I BE PUT PLEASE TO
SUPPORT ON THIS ITEM IN HOPES
THAT THERE ARE WAYS THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE THE STUDENT POPULATION
AS WELL AS THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION THE CENTER MONNING I
AND OUR ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED BEFORE I THINK THEY
DO GO HAND IN HAND BUT FIRST WE
GOT TO GET THE SKILLED LABOR
FORCE TO THE SCHOOL SYSTEMS. IN
IN THE WORK FORCE. THANK YOU
WITHOUT MOVED TO CENTER
CONSOLE. S. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR EVERYBODY'S COMMENTS
AND THINK YOU'RE SOME REMEMBER
RUBIO FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AS WELL. SO ALSO COMING FROM LA
COUNTY I THINK WHERE I HAVE A
BIT OF A CONFLICT WITH THIS
AUDIT IS THAT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY NELLY COUNTY AS WE
TALKED ABOUT THE SHORTAGE.
NURSES IS THE SHORTAGE OF
CLINICAL SPOTS AS THE OF MY-
COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED AS
WELL AND I KNOW THAT.
SPECIFICALLY WITH LONG BEACH
THE AREA I REPRESENT COMING
FROM THAT LENDS. A LONG WHICH
CITY COLLEGE WROTE IN
OPPOSITION THERE WERE EIGHT
NURSING PROGRAM BUT VERY FEW
SLOW. IN THE AREA. AND MAYBE IT
MAYBE IS THERE AN ADN PROGRAM A
FEW DIFFERENT ELEMENTS BUT-
THEY'RE VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. MORTGAGE HOSPITAL SITE IS
SLEEP. ANY I'M SPOT HERE AND IS
IT UP BUT I WOULD SAY IS THE-
YOU KNOW IT WITH LONG BEACH IN
ADDITION TO HAVING A DâN
PROGRAM AND THE SHORTAGE OF
SLOTS WE ALSO THE HOSPITAL
CLOSURE WHICH ADDS AND
COMPOUNDS TO THE ISSUE. AND SO
FOR ME IT'S A LITTLE DIFFICULT
TO SUPPORT AUDIT WHERE WE HAVE
YOU KNOW A MULTITUDE OF ISSUES
TO THINK ABOUT AND CARDS TO
THAT. I AM SO WHAT I WOULD JUST
SAY IS YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO UP
AND WORK CLOSELY WITH SENSIBLE
PROGRAMS THAT WE OF COURSE TO
STREAMLINE AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING. SLOTS IN AREAS
LIKE LA COUNTY AND THEN ALSO
LOOK AT SHORTAGE IS FOR NURSING
AND OTHER AREAS LIKE CENTRAL
VALLEY SO I THINK THERE'S A
WHOLE MIX OF IS THAT WE HAVE
TO. DO THAT I THINK. I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE
COMPREHENSIVELY. AND GAUGE WHEN
I THAT WE CAN DO FIRST. START
HEADING INTO AN AUDIT THAT MAIL
TACKLE ONE SPECIFIC ISSUE. SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU TURNING
BACK TO THE DíAS OF. UNSEEN
TAXES MOSTLY SURE I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT I DON'T SPEAK
FOR THE PROPONENT OF THIS
REQUEST AND I CERTAINLY DIDN'T
DRAFTED BUT ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
CALLS FOR OF THE AUDITOR TO
REVIEW AND IDENTIFY THE PROCESS
THAT THE BEER AND USES TO
EVALUATE CLINICAL DISPLACEMENT
IT CETERA SO THERE IS A
CLINICAL DISPLACEMENT ISSUE
WHICH I ASSUME MADAM AUDITOR
WILL ALSO INCLUDE AN EVALUATION
WHETHER THEY'RE SHORT CLINICAL
SLOTS WHERE THE COURAGE IS THE
REASON FOR THE SHORTAGES. IF
ALL UP YOU KNOW I THINK THERE'S
AN AT THERE'S BEEN APPS THERE'S
A LOT OF IT TOTAL INFORMATION
FLOATING AROUND BUT I THINK WE
NEED TO DRILL DOWN. BELOW THE
ANTIDOTE AND GET TO THE- TO THE
REAL FACT AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OR WHETHER
THIS IS JUST AN URBAN LEGEND.
AND IT MAY VERY WELL BE THAT
THEIR SHORTAGES THEY MAY BE
REGIONAL TO MAYBE NOT BUT I
WOULD I WOULD EXPECT THAT THAT
ISSUE TO BE SQUARE IT TO GO TO
MY- COLLEAGUES POINTS I WOULD
EXPECT THAT TO BE SQUARELY
ADDRESSED IN THIS AUDIT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU.
THIS TIME. FOR QUESTIONS FROM
DíAS WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. SQUARE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME IF
YOU CAN PLEASE. APPROACH
INDICATE YOUR NAME IF YOU'RE
AFFILIATED WITH AN ORGANIZATION
IF NOT. WHICH SCHOOL OR COUNTY
RESIDED IN WHETHER YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION TO THE
AUDIT IF YOU COULD PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO LESS THAN TWO
MINUTES THE CITY WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT. PLEASE HE'D
LIKE TO BEGIN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GEORGE MILLER ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN GOVERNORS UNIVERSITY
A NOT FOR PROFIT NURSING
SCHOOL. WE DO SUPPORT THE AUDIT
WE DO SUPPORT THE NEUTRAL.
PARTY BEING THE STATE AUDITOR
TAKING A LOOK AT THESE
QUESTIONS IN TRYING TO RESOLVE
SOME OF THESE ISSUES SAID OF
BEEN. OF CONCERN FOR A WHILE I
KNOW I DON'T THINK ANYBODY IN
THE NOT FOR PROFIT OR OTHER AND
PRIVATE NURSING SCHOOL SECTOR.
WOULD DISAGREE THAT IF THERE
ARE SLOTS AVAILABLE AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT THAT'S
PROBABLY THE BEST ROUTE THAT'S
THE LEAST EXPENSIVE ROUTE IT
USUALLY WERE CLOSEST TO THE TO
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT WANTS TO
GET AN EDUCATION AND IF IT
WORKS FOR THEIR DAILY LIFE.
THAT IS GOOD BUT IN OFTENTIMES
THAT ISN'T THE CASE WG WAS. WAS
ASKED TO COME TO CALIFORNIA TO
WORK AND A LOT. AND NOW
OFTENTIMES ARE RESPECT.
ACTUALLY COME FROM THE
HOSPITALS THEMSELVES THEY HAVE
STUDENTS THAT THEY WERE THEY
HAVE EMPLOYEES THAT ARE AT THE
HOSPITALS THAT THEY WOULD LIKE
TO. BECOME NURSES THEY'RE
ALREADY FAMILIAR WITH THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS BECAUSE
THEY'VE WORKED THERE. AND THE
ISSUE IS WE CAN'T GET. APPROVAL
WE'VE HAD THE HOSPITALS
THEMSELVES A CHIEF NURSING
OFFICER SIGN OFF THAT IT WILL
NOT DISPLACE ANY CURRENT.
COHORTS OF STUDENTS FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR OTHERWISE
AND WE STEUBENVILLE BEEN DENIED
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AS FEW
AS TEN STUDENTS. AND THESE ARE
REAL PEOPLE THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT THE HOSPITALS THEMSELVES
HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT WOULD
BECOME THAT WOULD BE GOOD
NURSES. AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
SUPPORT FOR THIS I ALSO BELIEVE.
YOU WANT TO GET NURSES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OR YOU WANT TO
GET A MODOC COUNTY YOU NEED TO
EDUCATE NURSES. WHERE THEY LIVE
AND THEY WILL BE MORE LIKELY TO
STAY THERE JUST LIKE EDUCATORS
AND I THINK. FOR PROGRAMS LIKE
OURS WE HAVE THAT CAPABILITY IF
WE CAN GET. RULES FROM THE BRN
THANK YOU. ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR MEMBERS AND
CURTIS LAYING FRAUGHT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION A
CNA AS OPPOSED TO THIS AUDIT
REQUEST BECAUSE IT IS AN
ATTEMPT BY PRIVATE NURSING
SCHOOLS TO MISUSE THE J. LACK
PROCESS A LOT PROCESS FOR THEIR
OWN GAINS BY PRESENTING OGDEN
QUESTIONS THAT WOULD YOUR-
ANSWERS TO FIT THEIR OWN
PURPOSES. BOB WE BELIEVE THAT
PART THAT PURPOSE IS TO. OUR IN
ANY ROAD ITS ABILITY TO PROTECT
NURSING STUDENTS IN OUR
PATIENTS. THIS IS JUST THE
LATEST ATTEMPT TO ACHIEVE THIS
AND FIRST THERE WAS LEGISLATION
BY THE PRIVATE SCHOOLS WHICH
WOULD HAVE THE REGULATED.
NURSING EDUCATION THAT BILL
DIED IN ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
THEN. THEY FILED A MASSIVE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST IN A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE B. R. AND-
NOW WE HAVE THIS AUDIT REQUEST.
INSTEAD CNA HAS SUBMITTED
ALTERNATIVE AUDIT QUESTIONS TO
THE AUTHOR WHICH WE BELIEVE
MORE DIRECTLY ADDRESSES THE
ISSUES SURROUNDING CLINICAL
PACE PLACEMENTS AND YOU SHOULD
HAVE THEM THERE BEFORE YOU.
THOSE QUESTIONS THE
JUSTIFICATION LARA IS FALSE
ASSERTION THAT CALIFORNIA'S
BUSINESS WHY NURSING SHORTAGE
WHICH IS BASED ON ALAR STUDY.
THAT USE A CRUDE CASTING
METHODS. AND IS SHORTAGE
NUMBERS WERE IN TO BE
IMPOSSIBLE. STEAD AS LEARNED
HERE TODAY THERE ARE REGIONAL
POCKETS WHERE AB SHORTAGES BUT
THE AREAS WHERE THE LARGEST
PRIVATE NURSING PROGRAMS ARE
CONCENTRATED ARE ACTUALLY AREAS
OF SURPLUS. SO IN ROAMING
GROWTH IN THOSE AREAS AS A
DIRECT IMPACT ON WHETHER
STUDENTS GET CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS. OF THE B. R. IN THE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC NOT TO PROMOTE THE
FINANCIAL INTEREST OF PRIVATE
CORPORATIONS OR CORPORATE
ENTITIES. AND ACTUALLY
HOSPITALS ARE ACTUALLY CONTROL
AND SET THE NUMBER OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS LOTS. PUBLIC UNIQUE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN DISPLACED
FROM CLINICAL SITES BY
HOSPITALS SO THAT RAPIDLY
EXPANDING PROPERTY PROGRAMS
COULD YOU THOSE SITES FOR THEIR
STUDENTS. FACT 27% A PRIVATE
INCORRECT STATE. ARE FROM ONE
PRIVATE SCHOOL. LET ME BE CLEAR
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THE HARD
WORK NURSING STUDENTS HERE
TODAY WE ARE NOT TRYING TO GET
RID OF PRIVATE NURSING PROGRAMS
AS AN ALTERNATIVE. BUT SEE IN
THE CNA BELIEVES IN THE NEED TO
SUPPORT MORE AFFORDABLE PUBLIC
EDUCATION RATHER THAN PUSHING
AN ALTERNATIVE THAT CAN COST
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND PUT
STUDENTS IN SUBSTANTIAL DEBT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO ALSO NOTE THAT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE THE
FUNDS THAT PRIVATE SCHOOLS HAVE
TO CLOSE SOME OF THESE GAPS IN
CERTAIN AREAS WHERE THERE ARE
GAPS. WE NEED TO MAKE PUBLIC
POLICY TO SUPPORT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. AS A PRIORITY.
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN PUBLIC
NURSING PROGRAMS ARE MORE
DIVERSE. MORE OFTEN THE FIRST
IN THEIR FAMILIES TO ATTEND
COLLEGE AND MORE LIKELY TO BE
FROM UNDER REPRESENTED IN AND
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR YOUR
NO VOTE ON THIS AUDIT. HI THANK
YOU AND I BELIEVE SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. LONG AS
THEY DON'T CHANGE THE SCOPE. OF
THE AUDIT THE AUDITOR WILL TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION IF I GET
HAVE EVERYBODY PLEASE BE MORE
SIX WITH YOUR COMMENTS. YOU'RE
SUPPORTING AND OPPOSING WOULD
APPRECIATE IT PLEASE I'LL BE A
LEASE MARGARET ON BEHALF.
FACULTY ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO DAUGHTER WELL ON OUR
THAT'S WHERE I CALL FROM CNH.
REAL REGARD. SCOPE AND ISSUE.
I'M NOT BEING. THANK YOU BAKER
I'M DO NURSING RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGE AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE EIGHTY FOUR.
AS A COMMUTE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS ALL OF WHOM WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS AUDIT. OF
CALIFORNIA. I HAD A LOT OF
OTHER REMARKS TO THEM BASED ON
YOUR QUESTIONS I HAVE TO SAY I
NEED TO CHANGE THEM. SIX OUR
AND WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA'S
COMES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE BEEN CLINICALLY DISPLACED
BY PRIVATE FOR PROFIT NURSING
PROGRAMS WHO ARE REALLY THE
AUTHOR IN THE IMPETUS BEHIND
THIS BILL AN ADJUSTER CORRECT A
COUPLE PEOPLE HAVE STATED THERE
IS A UP THERE ARE OPENINGS IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE I'M HERE TO
TELL YOU THAT IT'S NOT TRUE
THEY'RE NOT OPENING THE INLAND
EMPIRE THE LET EMPIRE BECAUSE
A- FULL. A NURSE FORCE. ALLEN
REJECTED IT WILL HAVE A SURPLUS
OF NURSES IN L'EMPIRE THE
SHORTAGES ARE LARGELY RELATED
TO THE- CENTRAL VALLEY I THINK
THAT THE ISSUE AS I THINK SAN
FRANCISCO IS ANOTHER AREA I
WANT TO SAY. AGAIN IT'S ANOTHER
AREA OF I'M UP NORTH I CAN'T
REMEMBER BUT THOSE AREAS NEEDS
INCENTIVE TO GET PEOPLE TO GO
TO THOSE AREAS AS OPPOSED TO
RAMPING UP IN THE NOT AREAS
WHICH ARE JUST. JEAN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE NURSING PROGRAMS SOME
PROGRAM AS ONE OF THIS IS AS
ONE OF THE. SOME WOMEN SENATORS
POINTED OUT IT IS 50% OF THEIR-
CLINICAL SPACES WERE LOST A FOR
PROFIT NURSING PROGRAMS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES COST SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS COST TWENTY FIVE
TO THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. PRIVATE FOR PROFITS COST
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. THE ATTRITION
RATE WHICH IS PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE ON THE B. R. AND
WEBSITE AT THE LARGEST FOR
PROFIT PROGRAM IS 25%
ATTRITION. THAT MEANS ONE OUT
OF FOUR OF THOSE P. A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS YOUR
DATA. PLEASE OKAY. I
RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK YOU ALL
TO OPPOSE THIS THE SUNSET
REVIEW CAN TAKE CARE OF THE
MATTER THANK YOU VERY MAKE YOU.
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TOM CAN SEE
ON BEHALF OF YOU A W. TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE REPRESENTING
ACADEMIC STUDENT EMPLOYEES THAT
YOU SEE. WE'D LIKE TO JOIN WITH
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS THAT
CNA AND CFA IN OPPOSITION THIS
AUDIT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY PLACE. I'M
CATHERINE HUGHES I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE I'M WITH A C.
I USED CALIFORNIA AND THE-
NURSE ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
NURSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I AM A PROUD ADN
GRADUATE I WENT TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IT TOOK ME FIVE YEARS
IT WAS WORTH EVERY SECOND. MY
DAUGHTER WENT TO NURSING SCHOOL
TO WATER THE LOOK AT A PRIVATE.
IT WAS GONNA COST OR EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GET HER AT
AND I TOLD HER NO. TOOK HER A
LONG TIME SHE GOT AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE AT RIVERSIDE
CITY COLLEGE SO. I AM A HUGE
SUPPORTER OF THE PUBLIC SYSTEM
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH POSITIONS FOR THE
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS. MY GOOD
OLD. FRIEND MEETINGS ALMOST ONE
OF THEM EVERY MONTH SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE OR- TEN. AND
STE. THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
TELLING US THAT THEY'RE
SHUTTING PROGRAMS DOWN. THERE
THERE ARE LIKE CUTTING THEIR
ENROLLMENT FOR THEIR
ELIMINATING A WHOLE SEMESTER
WORTH OF NURSING PROGRAM ROLE
MINUTES BECAUSE OF THE CLINICAL
DISPLACEMENT. SERVICE. THE BEER
IN THIS ADDRESSING SOME OF
THESE ISSUES THEY'VE DONE
REGIONAL SUMMITS WHERE THEY'VE
HAD STAKEHOLDERS COME TO
MEETINGS TO TALK ABOUT THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE WORKFORCE
MEANS THROUGH KNEE WALK WHICH I
AM A PROUD MEMBER OF THAT
WORKING COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS
THE WORK FORCE BUT THEY'RE
WORKING ON THESE ISSUES I THINK
THAT WE CAN DO IT THROUGH A
SUNSET REVIEW I DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO CORRECT WE ARE A PROUD
SUPPORTER OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING HAVE BEEN
FOR DECADES WE DON'T ALWAYS
AGREE AND WE ALWAYS HAVE SOME
CONSTRUCTIVE CRITICISM. BUT I
THINK WE'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE AND WE DO HAVE A LETTER OF
OPPOSITE. THANK YOU. NOT PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO THE ON IT FOR THE REASONS
AND QUESTIONS PREVIOUSLY STATED
WE WOULD ALSO JUST EMPHASIZE
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
IS ROLAND PUBLIC PROTECTION
PRETTY CLEARLY IDENTIFIED IN
THE BNP CODE AS THEIR PRIMARY
MISSION AND WE WOULD STRONGLY
ARGUE THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT
THEY'RE DOING BY ALIGNING THE
NUMBER OF NURSES TRAINED WITH
AN AVAILABLE SLOTS BECAUSE A
BIG PART OF. LEARNING TO BE AN
EFFECTIVE NURSE IS THAT DIRECT
PATIENT CARE EXPERIENCE AND THE
MORE THAT WE TRAIN NURSES
BEYOND THEIR BEING ACTUAL SLOTS
FOR THEM THE MORE THAT WE RISK
HARMING THAT COMPONENT OF THE
NURSE EDUCATION PROCESS AND SO
FOR THAT REASON UNDERSTOOD THAT
AND THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
DIRECTLY AFFECT THAT BUT THE
SUFFIX OF THIS ONE SO THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AROUND IT SCHEME
DESIGNED. IT WAS TOWARD THAT
GOAL AND SO WE WOULD URGE OTHER
A TO REJECT AUDIT START FIND
OTHER. GETTING TO THE SAME. NO
PROBLEM IS. GOOD AFTERNOON
JENNIFER TANNA HELL WITH ERIN
READING ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
WEST COAST UNIVERSITY WE HAVE A
VARIETY OF STUDENTS HERE
THAT'LL BE A SHARING THEIR
THEIR THEIR POINTS ON THIS WE
ARE FULLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUDIT TO DOCTOR WOODS POINT
ABOUT SUNSET REVIEW WE FEEL ON
IT WOULD IT WOULD GO A LONG
WAYS TEN BRING THE LEDGES AS
PART OF THE SENSE THAT REVIEW
PROCESS I'M AND WILL BE FILLED
IN THAT PROCESS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. THE WORD FULL
SUPPORT. DOES NOT COMMONPLACE.
HELLO I'M CAROLINE AND GUESTS
IRANIAN I AM A NURSING STUDENT
AT WEST COAST UNIVERSITY AT THE
LOS ANGELES CAMPUS I'M WILLING
TO MOVE TO WEAR THEIR SHORTAGES
IF THERE IS INCENTIVES AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE SITE. THANK YOU.
THIS IS A PUBLIC COMMENT. HI MY
NAME IS STILL PRETTY KILL I'M
FROM UNTIL CALIFORNIA I'M A
NURSING STUDENT AND I'M IN
FAVOR OF THIS AUDIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
LOUIS RENAULT UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS VETERAN NURSING
STUDENT BEING ONE WHO HAS HAD
DIFFICULTY NAVIGATING. THE
SYSTEM GETTING CLASSES IN BEING
AFFECTED BY THE WAIT TIMES I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THIS AUDIT THANK
YOU. ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
PLACE. I AM I AM ON A SAVAGE
NURSING STUDENT AT WEST COAST
AND I'M PROUD OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY CAMPUS AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AUDIT. THANK
YOU THIS NOVEL COMMENT. HELLO
MY NAME IS ERICA NIKI COLLEGE
STUDENT WEST COAST UNIVERSITY
PRODUCT OF A COMMUNICABLE AGE
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE SIDE
THANK YOU. OFFICIAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. HI MY NAME IS MELANIE
RIGHT I'M A SOON TO BE GRADUATE
FROM WAS BECAUSE UNIVERSITY LOS
ANGELES CAMPUS I'VE NINE MORE
WEEKS AND I AM FULLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS AUDIT. THANK YOU.
PLEASE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT HI MY NAME IS MORGAN
WHEN I AM A NURSING STUDENT IN
LOS ANGELES AND I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS AUDIT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU STUDENTS FOR
BEING HERE AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
MOVE INTO ANY OF OUR AREAS WITH
IT'S A NORTH COAST INLAND
EMPIRE THE VALLEY. WE
APPRECIATE YOU. ALL RIGHT
PLEASE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR
SCOTT ZEME I'M ASSOCIATE DEAN
FOR PRE LICENSURE PROGRAMS AND
ACCREDITATION AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO. I'M ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF THE COLLEGES OF
NURSING WHICH REPRESENT THE
PUBLIC AND THE PRIVATE SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE. I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AUDIT. I WANT
TO MAKE IT A GOOD FOLLOW UP TO
SOME OF THE KEY QUESTIONS WERE
RAISED EARLIER AROUND QUALITY
OF EDUCATION. I BRING A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF EXPERTISE
AS IT RELATES TO ACCREDITATION.
AND ASSESSING AND EVALUATING OF
THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION THAT
HAPPENS THROUGH NATIONAL
NURSING ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
COMMISSION OF KERR ON KLAY DID
NURSING EDUCATION OUT OF IT YOU
SEE IN. IN WASHINGTON DC WHO
REPORT UP TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. WHAT THE BOARD DOES
TOWARDS COMPLIANCE WITH
REGULATIONS THAT'S NOT THE
HALLMARK OF HOW HIGHER RED. X.
THE INSURERS THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION THIS IS A SUBTLE. BUT
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION TO BE
MADE. THE BOARDS REGULATIONS
ARE FREQUENTLY NON EVIDENCE
BASED FOR EXAMPLE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A YEAR'S WORTH OF DIRECT
PATIENT CARE EXPERIENCE IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS. TO BE
QUALIFIED TO TEACH IN A PRE
LICENSURE PROGRAM. I HAVE
PEOPLE WITH DOCTORAL DEGREES
MASTER'S DEGREES BECAUSE OUR
NURSE PRACTITIONERS BUT HAVEN'T
WORKED IN A HOSPITAL IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS. CANNOT BE
APPROVED TO BE TO TEACH I'VE
BEEN A NURSE SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH A DOCTORAL
DEGREE. I HAVE REPORTED TO THE
BOARD AS A DROP AS A DIRECTOR
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY ONE I WAS
A C. ASAP. I WAS ALSO THE
UNIVERSITY OF HAWAII WHERE
THERE WERE. DIDN'T THE SLIP
OVER. AND WE DID JUST FINE. NOW
THAT I MET YOU U. S. WE ARE
STRUGGLING THE OVERSIGHT OF THE
BOARD. IT FEELS LIKE MICRO
MANAGEMENT WE FEEL HEMMED IN WE
FEEL RESTRICTED AND WITH THE
PROMULGATION OF REGULATION WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
INFLUENCE INTO INTO SHIFTED SO
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
VALUE WE'VE BEEN IN LOTS OF
DISCUSSION WITH THE BOARD ABOUT
THIS FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. AND
WE HAVEN'T WRITING AND WE DON'T
GET RESPONSES. WE STRUGGLED
TREMENDOUSLY WITH THIS THE
WHOLE ISSUE ROOM CLINICAL
DISPLACEMENT IS MEMBER ROTH
MENTION WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
B. S. AND PREPARE NURSES IN THE
STATE ONLY SIXTY POINT FOUR
PERCENT. OR DELETE BSN PREPARED
WE NEED MORE BE A SIMPLE
PURPOSES WE WANT TO DO THIS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR EIGHTY IN
COLLEAGUES. THROUGH CONCURRENT
ENROLLMENT PATTERNS. THE ISSUE
OF CLINICAL DISPLACEMENT HAS
BEEN FOR HAS BEEN WE'VE GOT THE
WRONG ISSUE ON THE TABLE TO
WILL FIND WRONG SOLUTION. IT
ISN'T ABOUT BEING DISPLACED A
BECAUSE YOU'RE AN ATM PROGRAM
IN SAN FRANCISCO I AM IN
CONTACT WITH YOU SEE A STEP SAN
FRANCISCO STATE AND- CAL STATE
EAST BAY WERE ALL HAVE A
PROBLEM. EXCELLENT THANKS TO
THE BOARD FOR RAPING THE SUMMIT.
WE KNOW THAT THE PROPER
DIRECTION. CONSOLIDATE
SACRAMENTO AND POLITICAL PLACE
PLEASE SO THAT'S THE REAL ISSUE
AND I MEANT TO GET YOUR
TRANSPARENCY IN THIS AUDIT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT FOR THE
TEAMSTERS AND THE ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTISTS OF CALIFORNIA POSTED
AUDIT JUST VERY QUICKLY I LIKE
TO ADD THAT TO BE OUR AND ISN'T
THE ONLY BOARD THAT LIMITS
ENROLLMENT TO MAKE SURE ITS
LICENSEES ARE SAFE TO PRACTICE.
THE BOARD OF VOCATIONAL NURSING
AND PSYCHIATRIC TEST
TECHNICIANS ALSO WOMEN
ENROLLMENT AS WELL AS THEY THEY
HAVE THIS PRACTICE AND FIFTEEN
OTHER STATES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MATT BACK RIBS IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY SCHOOLS
I THINK I THINK IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THIS IS SORT OF
BECOME A FOR PROFIT VERSUS
NONPROFIT DEBATE THAT IS NOT
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT RIGHT SO
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF OUR SCHOOLS
WE HAVE GRADUATION RATES
PLACEMENT RATES COHORT DEFAULT
RATES THAT ARE ON PAR WITH
SCHOOLS LIKE STANFORD WE HAVE
HIGH PERFORMING SCHOOLS THAT
ARE DELIVERING THE NURSES THAT
YOU ARE ALL TALKING ABOUT THAT
YOU WANT. UNFORTUNATELY WE GET
TO THE ROOT OF THIS AUDIT
REQUEST IS WHAT LAWS DOES THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
HAVE THAT AUTHORIZES THEM TO
CONTROL THE ROMAN. THAT IS NOT
A CLEAR QUESTION. NOBODY HERE
THAT I HEARD FROM THE
SUPPORTERS DEFENDED. BELL LAW
THAT THEY BELIEVE THAT THEIR
CITING GIVES THEM THAT
AUTHORITY. WE NEED IN ORDER TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE BOARD TO
DETERMINE IF THEY HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY. HOW HAVE THEY BEEN
USING IT AND IF THERE ARE OTHER
BOARDS THE CONTROLLER MOMENT.
WAT OF THOSE GUIDELINES. THEY
DO NOT HAVE GUIDELINES FOR OUR
SCHOOLS AGO AND ASKED FOR A
MOMENT. IT IS A NEUTRAL REQUEST
IT IMPACTS COMMUNITY COLLEGES
YOU SEE SEE ISSUES FOR PROFITS
IN THE SAME MANNER. IT IS NOT
ADVANTAGE IN ONE SECTOR OVER
THE OTHER. IS LOOKING FOR AN
HONEST ASSESSMENT. WHAT RULES
APPLY TO THIS BOARD AND HOW
WERE THEY USING THEM. FOR A
SECTOR AND EVERYBODY ELSE SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR EITHER. THANK
YOU AT THE SOMEONE ASKED
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. HEARING AND SEEING
NINE I WILL TURN IT BACK TO THE
DíAS. AND LET ME JUST SAY YOU
KNOW THE ONLY THING I'LL ADD IS
LIKE YOU KNOW I HAVE BEEN PRIVY
TO SUNSET REVIEWS IN THE PAST.
I DO SEE THIS AS A WAY TO
INFORM THE SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS AND MOVING FORWARD AND
TRANSPARENCY I WANT TO JUST
LIVE MY COMMENTS PROBABLY WITH.
OUR VICE CHAIR WITH THIS ROD IN
THE PROPONENTS AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT AS WELL IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY. SENATOR ROTH IT'S
BEEN SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BASE. WITH THAT MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO APPROV WATER
REQUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DASH ONE TWENTY. BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING OVERSIGHT
OF PRE LICENSURE LICENSURE
NURSING SCHOOL PROGRAMS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SOUTH SIDE. SALAS HI
BOERNER HORVATH NO.
BOERNER HORVATH NO MAYES MAYES
I PATTERSON. ARSON AYE RUBIO
AYE RUBIO AYE VOEPEL VOEPEL I
WOULD. SENATOR ROTH ROTH HI
BORDERS FOR JUST I GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG MORNING MORNING NOW
MORE A LOT. SENATOR WINNER.
OKAY THAT ITEMS ON CALL AT THIS
TIME WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND USE THE SERGEANTS WOULD
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD
ON. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
GOODNESS FOR THAT MOMENT ON.
YEAH SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND GO
BACK TO THE BEGINNING AND WE'LL
START CALLING THE ITEMS. FIRST
IS THE SUSPENSION OF THE JOINT
RULES. SECTOR CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THAT GENTLEMAN AND THE
MOTION WAS TO APPROVE WAVING
COMMITTEE RULES THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN IN ORDER TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERNHARDT. BOERNER HORVATH HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES. THANK
YOU SENATOR ROSS SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR MINING
MONNING HI SENATOR WIENER. YEAH
BUT BUT. FOR THE TWENTY SECOND
I TO MISTER PERFECT AND SEND
CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DASH ONE
TWENTY FIVE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES SUICIDE PREVENTIONEFFORTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO ARE
ABOUT THAT BERMAN WERE ABOUT
WERE ABOUT BY MAYES. CENTER
HERTZBERG SENATOR MONEY MORNING
I. THIS MOTION WAS STRIPPER
WATER REQUEST NUMBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DASH ONE
TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE OVERSIGHT THE PET
LOVER SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATE
PROGRAM BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK. ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES. AT
CENTER HERTZBERG. THIS ITEM IS
ON CALL THIS IS TRUE THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE ATER QUEST NUMBER
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN DASH ONE
TWENTY SEVEN SAN DIEGO AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURNER WERE
ABOUT BOERNER HORVATH HI
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD WHAT I. SENATOR
BORDERS. SENATOR HERTZBERG. AND
SENATOR MORE LOCKED. OKAY WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND HOLD THE ROLE.
YEAH YEAH
. YEAH YEAH. YEAH YEAH.
OKAY YEAH. YEAH YEAH
. YEAH. BUT
I CAN'T VISUAL. THE COUPLE IS.
THE MOTION WAS APPROVED WAITING
COMMITTEE RULES THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN CENTER WINNER. WE. HI.
THE MOTION WAS YOUR PROVE AUTO
QUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DASH ONE TWENTY SEVEN
SAN DIEGO AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA I'M SORRY THAT WAS THE
WRONG ONE WE ARE. LOOKING AT
ITEM NUMBER. THE MOTION WAS TO
APPROVE ATER QUEST NUMBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DASH ONE
TWENTY BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING OVERSIGHT OF PRE
LICENSURE. NURSING SCHOOL
PROGRAMS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO SENATOR WINNER SENATOR
WIENER AYE
. OKAY
. LET'S SAY
THIS I DON'T WANT. I KNOW. YEAH.
YEAH THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE I
REQUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DASH ONE TWENTY BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING OVERSIGHT
OF PRE LICENSURE NURSING SCHOOL
PROGRAMS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO. CENTER MORLOCK. SENATOR
MORLOCK HI. MORE WORK. ALL
RIGHT YEAH. YEAH NO SIR SLAM TO
GO BACK AND LOOK AT IT YEAH.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR TWO MORE MINUTES FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON IF NOT
WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN. TWO
MINUTES
. YEAH
. EVER GLOBAL.
YEAH. SO WHAT WAS IT GRASSROOTS
ON THE. YEAH ALL RIGHT RESERVED
.
YEAH. YEAH. YEAH. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND ANNOUNCE THE.
THE VOTES FOR THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE. ON
THE MOTION TO WAIVE THE JOINT
ROLES THAT PASSES WITH ELEVEN
VOTES. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM AGENDA ITEM NUMBER ONE TWO
ZERO ONE NINE DASH ONE TO FIVE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
SUICIDE PREVENTION EFFORTS
PASSES WITH TWELVE VOTES. ON
THE REGULAR CALENDAR AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER TWO TWO ZERO ONE
NINE DASH ONE TWO ZERO BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING OVERSIGHT
OUR PRE LICENSURE NURSING
SCHOOL. THAT PASSES WITH NINE
VOTES. AGENDA ITEM NUMBER THREE
TWO ZERO ONE NINE DASH ONE TWO
ONE CALIFORNIA FORM OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE OVERSIGHT OF THE
PET LOVERS SPECIALIZED LICENSE
PLATE PROGRAM. PASSES WITH
ELEVEN VOTES. YES I DID ITEM
NUMBER FIVE TWO ZERO ONE NINE
DASH ONE TWO SEVEN SAN DIEGO
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
PASSES. WITH EIGHT TO VOTE NOW
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND CONCLUDE THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE THANK YOU